what an interesting uh past week or
weekend did you guys know that the
Grammys happened because I didn't uh I I
most people probably don't their ratings
are in the gutter they're down to like 9
million from a peak of 39 million 10
years ago so uh nobody's watching but I
guess in a desperate attempt to be
relevant they staged a satanic Grammy
performance with Sam Smith and Kim
Petras sponsored by Pfizer and it really
is that's sponsored by Pfizer which made
everybody laugh because I don't think
it's big news that an award show did
something Unholy or whatever they try
and do edgy satanic stuff all the times
all the time I mean we've seen this
stuff going back forever people trying
to be shocking or whatever and then uh
but this one was interesting because one
of the performers Kim Petras is mostly
well known for getting a sex change
operation as a child and so you have
this individual up on stage being
congratulated as the first trans woman
for receiving the ward and so there's
more to the conversation than just a
satanic performance this is a standing
over Invasion From Hollywood for child
sex change surgery so of course there's
a lot to talk about
in in so far as the Grammys are an
attempt at a culture role institution I
mean they were at one point not so much
anymore but that's probably good news
and we'll talk about that plus the
balloon it was shot down
then all of a sudden we get this report
from an anonymous official saying that
well under trump it happened three times
then you get three former top officials
named saying never happened and even if
it did like or and and you know you know
it didn't happen because nobody saw it
nobody took a picture of it no Pilots
complained there was no there was no
reports from any aviation industry uh
company or or individual like this one
we discovered it because people saw it
happen so it turns out probably one big
lie now they're claiming actually the
Biden Administration only just
discovered that three times the balloon
traveled over the U.S during the Trump
Administration and just nobody knew
it's amazing how that stuff works so
we'll talk about that
and a bunch of other ridiculous stories
apparently Hunter Biden is being touted
as like the next great artist or some
kind of great artist and uh there's an
article talking about his paintings
being sold for half a million dollars a
piece and we've wrote about this but you
know we got to talk about it and then
there's a famous Pro Surfer female who
is threatening to boycott the world surf
League unless they stop their new rule
which would allow biological males to
compete against females so this is
really interesting has to do with more
trans issues so we'll talk all about
that before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work directly you can click that
join us button if you want to get access
to exclusive members only segments of
this show Monday through Friday as well
as well as our other shows like the cast
Castle Vlog and tales from the infinite
World and uh you're also helping keep
our news team afloat make shows like
this it's all thanks to you as members
so become a member but don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel right now share the show with
your friends joining us tonight to talk
about all this and a whole lot more is
John Rich hey Tim John Rich who are you
I am a good old boy from Nashville and I
love your show make a little country
music and uh you know you guys came
through Nashville we got to hang out a
little bit just a little so I thought I
would uh come up to your neck of the
woods and see what's going on up here
right on and you gotta you got a new
song coming out soon is that what's
going on man I got something cool
happening so you know making country
music my whole life Big and Rich and all
that but I became a fan of this guy
during the pandemic
um started scrolling through watching
videos and I run across this guy and I
went what in the world is that and the
deeper I got into his music I thought
this guy's dropping more hammers per
square inch in these lyrics and maybe
anybody I've ever heard it's Tom
McDonald
and with this Tom McDonald guy is
vicious so I went and followed him on
Twitter
and a couple days later I checked and he
was following me on Twitter I said okay
I can send him a message so I sent him a
message I said hey I'm a country guy big
fan what do you know he he knew my music
and so we started talking back in that
summer and just kept in contact and and
I hit me up oh probably a couple months
ago and he says hey man I've got this
song called the end of the world do you
want to hear it I said oh yeah
I don't hear anything from Tom McDonald
he sends me the song and it was just
brilliant as it always is with him he
goes you want to sing the choruses man I
said me and you like a duet you know
like together he goes yeah I go wow the
Cowboy and the the the rapper with the
face tattoos from California doing a
song together he goes yeah man if you
want so I sang on it and it turned out
really great and uh working on shooting
the video and we'll put it out it's up
to Tom when it comes out but he says
very soon it's probably the end of this
month or next month so right I'll be on
the lookout for that cool man thanks for
joining us should be a lot of fun we
also got Hannah Claire hanging out hi
I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com I also occasionally go
on pop culture crisis I'm working on
making my intro longer per request uh
but yeah thanks for having me on tonight
that was awesome John awesome to see you
again my man you too yo we went to your
house I know we took a tour of the place
is phenomenal you got a huge stage we
played on yeah saw the rooftop garden
not really a garden mostly grass and
things like that on the roof yeah thanks
again it was excellent I still like this
is incredible feelings from that
Nashville visit I hope to do it again
someday you have to do this show from
that stage in the house house and like
set the band up and do the whole thing
oh that sounds good you know what I mean
rock and roll yeah hell yeah next time
we're in Nashville I'm Ian Crossing if
you don't know it check it Serge du
preya what's up I am at surge.com on
Twitter I'm ready to get started all
right here's the first story we got this
from the post millennial breaking
Sam Smith stages satanic Grammy
performance with strippers and devil
horns Petrus danced in the cage Smith
wore devil horns while dancers in long
red robes with straight hair fond around
him in a ritual Circle all right I'm
gonna say it first off and and and first
and foremost yeah I don't I don't really
care about artistic faux satanic
whatever but there's more to the story
than just a performance of the Grammys I
think it was uh Brett dasovic from pop
culture crisis was mentioning that
Marilyn Manson did stuff like this in
the 90s it's not shocking to be edgy and
be like ooh I'm gonna wear devil horns
but there's a couple things about it
notably and we have this tweet
brought to you by Pfizer Let's uh let's
let's play it so you've got you know Kim
Petras and Sam Smith you know cheering
and getting some award and then this
[Music]
is
[Applause]
it just really feels like
um a trifecta of right wing talking
points happening all at the same time
you have an un the song is called Unholy
satanic imagery brought to you by Pfizer
and one of the individuals uh Kim Petras
is famous I believe I believe Kim is
from Germany and is famous for appearing
in a documentary requesting a sex change
operation at the age of 13 or 14 and
actually having received it as a minor
so
all of these things together we're not
just talking about an artistic show
that's meant to be shocking and edgy
there actually are elements that many
people are shocked by but I don't know
what do you guys think is this uh I
don't know people overreacting or is it
just I don't think brought to you by
Pfizer is an overreaction that's weird
man corporate I mean this is is far away
from Rock and Roll as you can possibly
get as corporate Pfizer like corporate
money drug drug companies I mean hey
they made 50 what do they make like 50
billion dollars 100 billion or something
in profit I don't know what was the
number
I don't know was it that much Pfizer
yeah like one year yeah or maybe in the
past two years I made like 100 billion
or something you have guaranteed
government contracts that's basically
free money you know John you've been to
the Grammys yeah multiple times you say
yeah I've been nominated for nine
Grammys the house throughout my career
how many satanic performances did you
see uh to date I've done a total of zero
satanic performances so I guess I'm not
the cool kid anymore yeah I think it's
to see this sponsored by Pfizer brought
to you by Pfizer I thought oh there's
the drugs and the sex drugs and rock and
roll maybe that's what that is just
different kind of drugs yeah the kind
that you have to take that nobody knows
what it's going to do well you ever hear
that like I don't know old Trope of the
hippie becoming the business person when
they get all like the Boomers we're all
young and wild and crazy and then they
become suits later on I mean I'm
wondering if the real story there is
that the hippie State hippies and suit
stayed suits and we just assume that
because Boomers were hippies Boomers be
like this hippies became suits or
whatever but it's like it's just a funny
thought that sex drugs and rock and roll
goes from being in the alley in the
gutter and just STDs doing hard drugs
and playing music and just degeneracy to
on a stage in a multi-million dollar a
billion dollar industry with
choreography and performances and
pharmaceutical drugs yes not street
drugs what I got is this doesn't even
really satanic this is like if satanics
like Ozzy Osbourne chewing the head off
of a live bat that was an accident yeah
it was an accident but he did and
there's blood on stage maybe not satanic
Ozzy maybe not people pouring blood on
themselves on stage like dark you know
that's a little more satanic this is
like the image of Satanism it's not even
real Satanism it's it's all foe like
they put on red and they have fire
behind them but it's like supposed to be
it's called it's even called Unholy like
it's supposed to be satanic I don't know
I don't know maybe maybe the singer who
is advocating for child sex change
surgery is the thing that's Sam Smith
I'm just gonna say Sam Smith ripped off
Tom Petty with that well back down won't
you stand High Ground that song that he
did he got soft for and he lost him
pretty sure yeah Tom Petty ended up his
ended up making uh residuals off that I
think he passed part of the whole
performance is that it's so surface
level right like truly provocative
things your audience is going to stand
up and applaud afterwards so great good
job like this was no matter they could
have done anything they could have gone
out there and done nothing stood still
and the audience would be like wow
groundbreaking amazing performance so
glad that you guys did that uh I think
part of the I think you're totally right
it's not even a a very uh original uh
depiction of like Satan and like
semi-anti-christian imagery I think it's
sort of cheap and done to make it seem
like we are still counter-cultural but
really they're not they are the
mainstream supported by a major drug
company coming out and uh promoting
talking points that are more and more
part of the mainstream narrative like
yes everything we're doing is okay it's
it's like they want to be edgy and they
can't anymore you know you know what I
I'm just not into is
it seems like the principal commentary
in all this is that the performance was
satanic and I'm just like okay you know
if you want to talk about Sam Smith
non-binary child sex change operations
Pfizer being the sponsor but let's talk
about massive multi multi-billion dollar
corporations sponsoring satanic shows
that I can get but it seems like most
people are just saying like look they
wore devil horns and they were dancing
in red I can't believe it this is pure
evil and I'm like well what what about
it because I mean are we gonna seriously
we'll go back and talk about any any
death metal band or like black metal in
Scandinavian all the dark demonic
imagery they they use I do like there
was more backlash when uh Miley Cyrus
came out and like twerked on someone at
one of the award shows right that's
arguably more satanic being sexual and
people were more upset about you heard
more of both sides being like she's so
liberated that's inappropriate whatever
this it's just like yes we're completely
falling on party lines right there are
the people who are annoyed by it are
annoyed and the people who like it like
it I mean there's no Nuance to it
anymore if they had if it had been green
light all green and they were wearing
Shamrock hats no one would mention
Satanism and it would be called they
don't even question why it's called
Unholy so it's like the the it's like
the Visage of of evil just to like sell
tickets they're like look how dark yeah
it would have been an awesome show if
they were green with Shamrock cats that
have been I'd have been into it then the
Irish Community is like take it back
immediately what's wrong with us well
the whole point the whole point you
spend millions and millions of dollars
for visual
visual elements to music
is to sell more music it's to sell music
sell tickets it's it's to push the music
further like you got a song you want to
put a great video behind it so more
people see it and hopefully love the
song and it becomes your thing and and
people sit around and have really big
meetings around really big tables like
this at record labels and they spend
tens of millions of dollars behind a lot
of these artists all for marketing of
the music of that artist and marketing
the artists so more people will want to
consume that content so when you look at
this performance on the Grammys they're
sitting there going what's going to make
the most people
like this artist like this music you
know come to come to the party here I
know what let's just simulate hell
on stage and then let's tag it with
Pfizer which is the biggest cuss word in
America right now
this is the pitch so what does that what
does that say about what they think
about the audience that this is what
they're going to pour their money into
for the visual backups of the music yeah
they probably think we're really
gullible and we'll bite and start
talking about it on TV exactly and we
did I did um but that cuts both ways
because you want people to like it we
don't like it we're seeing it we're
repulsed by it but you know this is what
happens with with everything culture War
related a lot of these big companies
know uh I'll give you an example when uh
Jim Jordan was talking we'll get super
political Jim Jordan's talking with uh
Chuck taught him on Meet the Press and
he says you know with with Donald Trump
you had the Secret Service protecting
these documents you had them locked you
had the doj actually came in and put the
lock on it with Joe Biden they're stored
in a garage Chuck Todd immediately comes
the defense of Joe Biden despite the
fact that any sane reasonable thinking
person is going to be like what the you
talking about like Chuck Todd's like no
no no Trump did it Trump did it and it's
like he just laid out for you the
details of the story you're not refuting
them you're just saying yeah well Trump
is bad what they're doing is
20 2012 they had 39 million viewers the
most they've ever had the year before
was like 29 typically averaged around 27
28 million viewers then there's this
massive drop-off from 2019 of like 18
million viewers to 8 million then in 20
in 2021 I think 2020 to 2021 then in
2022 they had
I think about 8.93 million they have no
audience nobody watches
they'll take anything they can get
they're they are so desperate for
attention and I imagine there's probably
some executive or somebody associated
with the Grammys and they're sitting
there saying like guys
we lost 60 of our viewers we're dead in
the water what do we do and they were
like people aren't going to want to
watch shows like this we need
controversy we need to piss people off
and here's the hope
get a bunch of conservatives angry and
at the very least you will rescue a
liberal audience so they start posting
stuff like this hoping that shows like
this generate rage but not that we will
watch it that the tribalists in the cult
will say well we're big fans of the
Grammys and then they will start
endorsing it and the Machine will then
prop up the Grammys I think to your
point uh Beyonce won I think she just
became the most grammy-winning artist of
all time at this Grammys right Beyonce
is one of those things that like she's
one of these artists that like can do no
wrong and people even if her music is
bad even if she's not interesting even
if she's involved with Scandal even if
her husband or her sister is filmed
hitting her husband in an elevator like
she survives anything she's bulletproof
so to be like and we're bringing back
Beyonce who can who you will rally
around no matter what is sort of this
way to keep an audience that you know
they're not trying to win us over
they're trying to win their base back
over uh and I mean Beyonce won for uh
Renaissance right this is like just
after she performed in um
in the Middle East in a country that's
completely anti-lgbtq even though her
her album is supposed to be based off
the black LGBT experience like it it
doesn't make any sense they don't have
to follow their own rules they just have
to bring out the figureheads that they
like and know that you'll cheer for them
because it's making someone else angry
someone you don't like angry I didn't
know Beyonce performed until just now I
care so little about this I'm a musician
and I don't even I talk to me this I I
credit all of this knowledge to pop
culture crisis I go on and they teach me
about these things uh I knew she was
performing because an influencer that I
follow on occasion was at this big
private Resort opening and she was
performing for like some crazy amount of
money but what happened to music John in
the last decade
well uh that's a great question I just
hearing and you're right about what
they're what they're trying to do is to
you said Salvage what's left of their
liberal base that's a good way to put it
but then I have to think well what's
wrong with that base
that that would Salvage them well I
think I mean you understand that's how
regular people look at like I'm a dad I
got two sons you know they can't I'm not
gonna let them watch the Grammys I mean
one of my sons caught a little piece of
it and said Dad it looks like they're
all in hell
and I said no we're in hell for having
to watch it let you know change the
channel I mean he was going what am I
looking at you know a little kid who
loves music and he's seeing that go on
like like Sam Smith is being devoured by
demons on the stage when they push him
down at the end like they're eating him
or whatever that was supposed to be and
then brought to you by Pfizer my son
goes
the vaccine companies behind this I went
yeah he's 11. well so it used to be that
there were very few channels cable TV
didn't get really that much ratings
because it costs money and so the
Grammys probably got 30 million viewers
because people turned on the TV yeah and
that's what was on everybody was talking
about it then the internet started
becoming more and more prominent YouTube
videos I remember back in the day in the
early days of YouTube you could put out
a video on these big channels we get
like a million hits because it was there
was very few there was very there was
very little content on it that was worth
watching a bunch of weird stuff like a
person filming a birthday party then all
of a sudden higher quality content but
as more and more people started to use
the internet things are decentralized
and viewers are to flatten out so I
remember talking to some big YouTubers
who were like you know we used to get a
million million and a half now we get 50
to 100K and I'm like well yeah now
you're competing with 10 100 times as
many people so the ratings for everybody
drops and what ends up happening is
extremism and drama and uh hard hard
like view politics are your path to
getting clicks so the thing about news
is that everybody knows everybody knows
everything right the balloon happens
someone posts on Twitter there's a
balloon over Montana instantly everybody
knows so there's no there's no news
channel you can't make a news show and
be like ladies and gentlemen there's a
balloon over Montana I think like dude I
heard that on Twitter instantly you're
telling me nothing so what ends up
happening is that news programs become
people programs where they talk about
their view of the news like what we're
doing quite literally but more
importantly they realize there's more
views in talking about personal issues
so here's what ends up happening with
something like this
in my view
they know they're never getting back
those 39 million viewers because that
was a captive audience
but if they're going to get back any
amount of viewers they need to create a
tribe that will latch onto them do this
and you will get Hardline hard politic
woke liberal people who will defend you
and watch just because you're on their
side that's how it works
so I think if this is the path things
are going part of me wonders if these
platforms will die off because I'm
hoping you know here's my gamble human
nature is some people may want the shot
content the the tribalism and the drama
and some people might want the
conversation and I'm hoping the
conversation the ideas are actually
what's going to win but I got to be
honest I'm not the most confident
considering that these companies keep
doing stuff like this they're not
backing down maybe they'll fail and got
a business and will all be proven right
or maybe what's going to happen is
you're going to find that humans really
do just want to consume gutter trash
Coliseum content watch the Lions rip
apart the Gladiators yeah uh you're
talking about the Grammys the people
that the company that runs that might go
bankrupt at some point is that the
company we're talking about their views
are down from two years ago by 60 some
odd percent it's no longer that we have
to wait a year to hear what like 30
people think is the best song on Earth
you know some awards ceremony used to be
now the Grammys should have their own
YouTube Network or their own network
where every week you go there and
there's new videos and songs on
grammy.com or whatever they should pivot
like waiting for the Oscars to show to
tell me what was good I already know I
saw it I don't need it and the word
shows used to have this exclusive
exclusivity to celebrities right like
they're coming down the red carpet and
what are you wearing and who do they
bring as their date but now you see all
of that on social media any celebrity
who's appearing at these event has some
sort of social media following so some
of the mystery of you know being removed
when we didn't have social media when
you were waiting you had to watch the
broadcast to get all of these details
about these people that you look up to
or you're interested in or you're
following or whatever like you can get
that a drop of a hat now so you're right
like the Grammys and all the other award
shows need to adapt after die because I
don't think anyone looks I'm very few
people I definitely don't look to these
institutional award shows to say like ah
yes I you have recommended a good song
to me I will listen to it now you know
like it it doesn't mean anything anymore
you're more likely to get a reference
from someone you know personally and
then you don't have this Elite space
where you're saying oh well I get to see
the celebrities live you see them all
the time they're Overexposed on social
media let's jump to the story from the
Daily Mail I saw actually this tweet
first from Jack besobic woke Disney
Sparks outrage with new kids cartoon
that claims America was built on slavery
as it pushes reparations and says
Lincoln had no desire to liberate the
enslaved that last part's true Lincoln
had no desire to liberate the enslave
that's a fact anybody who reads about
Civil War knows that even the
Emancipation Proclamation only applied
to States and Rebellion from the United
States meaning there were several uh
northern states that had slavery that
were exempt from it however I think this
is uh
what we were just talking about is the
desperate attempt to generate tribalism
form for money mission driven
storytelling because an entertainment
product won't cut it anymore and I think
that's what this is more about but this
also results I mean look look at this
this is what they're teaching your kids
the U.S still has not atoned for slavery
and look how pissed off these characters
are you're supposed to your kids are
going to watch this and they're going to
see a bunch of angry young people saying
unites us it's not a toned for this and
they demand reparations when in reality
the United States has in my opinion more
than atoned in in a lot of ways and in
ways that it's not politically correct
to talk about and that no one none of
these people have an honest conversation
with you about and they will teach your
kids because two things are happening
one the industries are dying they need
to find a way to make money how are they
going to do it okay let's we're not
going to get a general audience anymore
General audience is no longer a thing
with the decentralization of the
internet and streaming platforms you
need directed audience you need a core
audience choose what your audience is
when I worked for Fusion they said our
target audience are young progressives
and that means we are going to side with
them and tell the stories they want to
hear outright sang as a media company we
are here to say what they want to hear
deliver them a product not we try and
capture everybody and tell them the news
that was their mission that's what this
is and so what I see here is is the
other thing is
it's a long game man you're gonna you're
gonna sit here and be like well you know
it's one show whatever those kids are
gonna grow up it's the only thing
they're gonna hear because people are
too scared to speak up and then this is
what they're getting from their from
from Disney and parents thinking in
their minds Disney is like Bambi are
buying this for their kids but instead
their kids are being told that America
sucks has never atoned and you know
angry it's what you're going to end up
with is a group of young people who are
extremely unhappy
hopeless and pissed off well I think
when you said long ball another thing
came to my mind which is there's a lot
of people Americans born and raised
Americans and big powerful positions all
throughout our country that dream of the
day where America is no longer a
stand-alone independent entity they want
to see one world money one world
Military One World Medicine one world
everything and you can't have one world
anything as long as the United States is
still standing on both feet and able to
hold its own so if you can
disincentivize kids brainwash them and
grow them up into a young adult of
military age that is not willing to
fight for their country they don't think
their country is worth fighting for
guess what they won't fight for their
country and they won't be too upset if
somebody wants to come in here and take
the place over or take it down you know
if you think about the World War II
generation had the great benefit of
being around grandparents uh my
granddaddy multiple purple hearts in
World War II you're around those people
you know my grandmother's dragging metal
in from the ditches around Texas to the
schoolyard where they would melt it down
and turn it into tanks and airplanes and
bullets
that's what they had to do to save not
only United States but the whole world
you don't have that attitude with a lot
of young people right now and stuff like
this Disney crap you say parents think
that Disney's teaching their kids
showing their kids something good more
and more parents Tim are waking up to
the fact that Disney does not have the
best interests of their kids at heart I
can promise you you can look at the
stats on how many people are visiting
Disney right now it is plummeting
because people realize hang on these
people are trying to brainwash my kids
these people are trying to teach my kids
instead of me teaching my kids now I
don't know who in her as kids maybe I'm
the only one but nothing we talked about
this last time I was with you nothing
will bring out the vicious teeth of a
mom or a dad more whether they're a
left-leaning parent Center or
right-leaning parent nothing brings
their teeth out faster than thinking
some stranger is taking their autonomy
and Authority away from their own
household that is when the fists come up
and so Disney's just doing it on a
multi-billion dollar level but again
it's like the Grammys it's so blatant
now we used to accuse them of you know
what they're really trying to do right
and they'd say oh go put your 10-pole
hat back on they're not doing that well
we don't have to accuse them of it
anymore because it's right in front of
our faces and parents are waking up to
it so good I'm glad Disney is doing that
it's just another another strike against
them as far as I'm concerned one of the
most frustrating things about the whole
woke ideology is one it's
I mean look if you want to make an
argument about slaves building the
country and operations we can have the
conversation doesn't necessarily have to
be rooted in critical race Theory and
stuff but the critical race Theory stuff
is resulting in segregation racial
animosity and there's been numerous
polls I think Gallup ran a poll that
said people view racial tensions in this
country worse now you know after the
Obama presidency than before like
following his presidency all we got from
the left was race race race
and and this is you know I'm growing up
in a world where they're passing laws
and and uh there's court rulings to end
discrimination based on race and you end
up now with this the US has still not
atoned for slavery which is just
generating in my opinion more racial
animosity that's you know I'll put it
this way when I said that I think this
country more than atoned how about how
many people died in the in the Civil War
like 1.8 million or something like that
yeah now granted there's a lot of
Confederates there but let me just point
out the Confederacy doesn't exist
anymore it's gone and so so after the
the the states that wanted slavery were
crushed in one of the most bloody
military conflicts ever I'd have to
argue that the north
militaristically crushing The South was
and then all of the all of the
Northerners who oppose slavery uh and it
wasn't completely about slavery mind you
I understand that but the end of slavery
brought about through the Civil War I
think is uh it counts as atonement on
the part of the north at the very least
and the South no longer exists after the
South Was Defeated they were occupied by
Northern forces in the Reconstruction
Era which didn't end until there was
almost another civil war so when they
come out and they're like this country
still hasn't atoned I'm like I don't
know I kind of think like half a million
800 000 dead soldiers fighting to end
the expansion of slavery at the very
least which resulted in the end of
slavery sounds like atonement for me uh
to me and then also keep in mind that
much of the country's expansion and
development have to happened after this
in fact one of the key components of the
Civil War was that Abraham Lincoln was I
I could be getting this wrong it's been
a while to read about it there's people
who know more than me obviously
academics but what was really happening
was the current state of politics was to
stop the expansion of slavery into new
territories as they became States so
California for instance was never a
slave state it entered as a free state
was always a free state and so that was
it was ending the expansion slavery was
was being uh suppressed essentially so
they want to argue it was never atoned
for but I'm like man Not only was the
political environment to shut it down
slowly over time with massive resistance
those who tried to keep it were crushed
with military force and you want to talk
about atonement how about Sherman's
March to the Sea and the decimation of
family homes and cities and Villages or
the ransacking and burning of Richmond
this this kind of stuff pisses me off
because it's a bunch of ideological
blowhards and they put out these videos
I watched one where This Woman's like we
should abolish private property also I'm
moving into my own house it is it it is
psychotic lunacy that's going to result
in in my opinion all of these good
things things that we've retained while
getting rid of the bad will be destroyed
we'll be wiped out and then we'll all be
left holding empty bags in the middle of
the woods fending for ourselves yeah I
was gonna say this show The Proud Family
aired in the early 2000s so I remember
watching it as a kid and I'm kind of sad
to see them injecting this very
obviously uh pointed ideology into it
because it was one of the first TV shows
I remember seeing I think it is the
first time I remember seeing uh Muslim
characters depiction on television yeah
true there's like a whole episode where
she like the penny the main character
does kind of like an exchange but it's
within her own School District with a
Muslim family and just uh where hijab
and like talk about it and whatever else
and like there are ways to talk about
culture and ways to talk about the
challenges different people face coming
into America without it being like let's
all blame one person let's have it be
about how this country is bad you know
this show is actually interesting and
this is the reboot I wish they would
have stuck with what they were trying to
do in the early 2000s like inclusion
diversity equity and inclusion that's a
big part of the critical race theory is
the inclusion of it so why exclude why
why talk about evil and them and those
if you really want to include people in
the process and I will also say we this
country was born on the backs of British
slave British subjects British subjects
that had to fight a war to overthrow
their slave master King George
the whole thing all of us come from
slaves can you name another country that
fought a civil war
over slavery in large part name any
other nation in the history of the
planet
they've all had slaves every Empire had
slaves is there any other one that
fought a civil war to end it now that I
think I'm going to think I think it's
just us yeah I'm gonna start look
searching because maybe there is I don't
know one off the top of my you know they
come out for these kids young the the
CRT stuff
um that even landed in a little too
close to home a few years ago and I I
read it and I'm looking at it and I'm
thinking about there's my son sitting
next to his best friend who he plays
baseball with who's black my son's a
white kid and they're both reading the
same thing and it's saying if you're
this color then this is what you're
about and if you're that color you don't
have a chance and these both these kids
are looking at each other going my son
felt like he needed to apologize he's
like man I didn't know you know they're
little kids and the other kid felt
terrible because he's like what do you
mean I don't have a chance we both hit
home runs last weekend it's all
negativity oh it's terrible it is mind
torture right yeah it's it's just it's
just disgusting well and like this is
his best friend right are they going to
spend the rest of the time they go to
school together being like Oh wait
there's actually something terrible I
would if they didn't have parents that
told them hey that's nonsense that's
right and a lot of kids don't have
parents like you're right A lot of them
don't yep
I I I'm trying to follow up on this it
looks like maybe Brazil fought a
revolution to overthrow slavery was this
Pedro Emperor Pedro I'm getting this all
wrong I need more data it's like sign up
to look at quora I don't want to sign up
guys well in uh in the UK they uh
abolished slavery I think a couple
decades before the United States did so
the argument from a lot of these people
is that if the U.S never had
Independence
and it was just a colony of the UK
slavery would have ended a lot sooner I
kind of don't think so I think the Civil
War would have just been the southern
Revolution I mean it's basically what it
was the Confederacy was trying to secede
from the union make their own country
and if the UK was doing the same thing I
had imagined they would have done the
exact same thing the only difference is
they'd be fighting against the the crown
I don't know what the strength of the
crowns at that point it'd be a really
interesting history to see like the War
of 1812 actually ends up as some kind of
conflict over slavery or probably not
because I think it was like 1830 or
whatever the UK finally abolished it or
something like that but I don't know man
long story short
I think the people who write this stuff
they just have no idea what they're
talking about and that's a lot of what
guides culture in uh for humans
and man I don't know it's kind of
depressing right uh Bill Maher did this
really great segment I guess last week
talking about how cultural
revolutionaries want to erase human
nature and you can't Mao want to get rid
of the four Great olds or whatever old
culture and stuff like that and you
can't do it
and then he says in the Soviet Union
they had this idea of like the strong
Soviet man who cared more about being a
part of a collective than of
individualism and then Bill Maher makes
the joke that um when in reality the
Soviet man just wanted to wear a
tracksuit be on a yacht with a beautiful
woman and then he chose a guy in a
tracks or whatever but the thing about
the reason I bring up Bill Maher is that
you know he's very much in line with a
lot of this stuff too notably his Prager
you uh uh I'm sorry his Prager uh
interview not interview but the
conversation when he was on the panel
and Prager said they're putting tampons
in the men's room and and Bill Maher
laughed at him like Bill Maher may be
doing better than a lot of these
mainstream default liberal types when it
comes to not under uh when it comes to
understanding some of the news and
what's happening in our culture but even
he's behind and so you end up with Bill
Maher who's supposed to represent like a
higher class of political commentary you
know it's it's smarter than Jon Stewart
but still funny things like that and
even they don't have any any idea what
they're talking about they're not
reading current news are not talking
about current cultural issues they're
behind the curve by a couple years
so I don't know man uh part of me is not
particularly hopeful to be completely
honest if everything is racist then
nothing is racist yeah true and so the
best way to keep people fired up about
racism because I I believe that that
people that push crap like this they
want to see racism they need to see
racism they need that hatred to exist so
they have a reason to go out and make
the money that they make doing whatever
it is the angle that they're pushing and
so you know the best way to do that is
anybody that I disagree with I'm going
to call them a racist yeah and then the
other person goes we weren't even
talking about that what do you mean I'm
a racist they go no you're a racist you
just don't know it that's part of the
CRT thing is you don't even know that
you're a racist but you are it's like
trust me it's like vaccines and Pfizer
right yeah you know you need another one
now you need a booster now you need
another thing like if you solved racism
who would fund all these non-profits
right like exactly what happened to me
in 2016 best friend in La we were
talking talk politics every day pretty
much well we would watch Rachel Maddow
and he'd have CNN on the backgrounds
talking about Hillary Clinton's emails
and their servers and like oh my gosh
look at what she did with Sydney
Blumenthal with Osprey Global Solutions
in Libya at a gun run for you know it's
basically privateering he's getting
Sydney Bloom with all this money and
he's like you're white privilege you've
got white like it just came down to
you've got white privilege and I it was
the first time I'd ever been told that
in my life and I was like what the hell
is going on I'm talking about Hillary's
emails dude look look at the data and
he's like you're just you're just racist
you're a white your white privilege is
coming out and it was shocking blown uh
powerless I didn't know how to respond
how no wasn't enough no I'm not isn't
enough if they keep saying it over and
over and I just had to disengage I left
I haven't talked to the guy hardly it's
really one of the worst things you can
call somebody what's what's worse
than being called a racist well there's
a lot worse things I don't know I mean
that's like if you were actually a
racist like a real racist that's one of
the nastiest humans around if you're an
actual racist I mean I've run into a
couple of them and you're like wow I
don't want um you know I mean they're
they're really nasty people uh from from
all sectors of the world that that are
true racist so when you're called one
and you're not one and that word gets
thrown around so flippantly it
at this point it almost has lost lost
its sting because everything like I said
if everything's racist then nothing is
racist most countries in the world are
extremely racist the United States in my
opinion is the least racist place I've
ever been totally I think Sweden may
have been one of the most racist places
I've ever been you know and and uh they
they masquerade as opposing racism yeah
but then they're like super racist but
you know I mean they can think that
they're not racist because they have
homogeneous society right like this
argument gets mean about Japan all the
time they're very strict on immigration
you cannot live in Japan but Sweden's
issue is that they they kind of don't
they have pockets of racial minorities
from other parts of the world that
they've boxed in claimed they're they're
they're not racist and then segregate
these people from their own society and
refuse to hire them while acting like
they're all Progressive that's that's
what I mean like at least in Japan
they're honest about them being like our
country is Japan for the Japanese so you
can't come here Sweden's like oh we love
and care about everybody you know
they're allowed to come here everybody
in the box and then I I heard this from
a lot of people even Americans I heard
an American woman who moved to Sweden
saying that they wouldn't hire her
because she had an accent she spoke
Swedish but had an accent and they were
like nope
there's like no integration did you get
that too traveling around you've been
around how many countries have you lived
in search
um I have no idea probably like 10 or so
you were nodding when Tim was saying
America's United States is the least
racist Yeah by far and people just don't
realize that because they've rarely been
in other places so they often talk from
an American perspective about these
things and think that you know people in
for instance China oh they're not you
know they're like not they're extremely
racist if they're Han Chinese against
even other Chinese like people within
China so China you say should we talk
about China China what what a perfect
opportunity for a Segway good timing all
right let's jump to the story we got
this from timcast.com Chinese
surveillance balloon may have contained
explosives designed to self-destruct
anytime you down something like this we
have to make assumptions such as that's
uh such as that said Air Force General
Glenn D vannert I wonder if that's the
real reason they did not want to shoot
it down because the debris is one thing
but if it had some something in it
really bad I guess the concern is what
if it had a bomb would have had some
kind of device and shooting it down
would
yeah you know poison or a biological
weapon you said it before the show I
think John the EMP the best way to
deliver it would be or one of the best
ways would be via balloon because it's
so high up and then it's got just a wide
berth of explosives it goes higher than
an airplane can go to shoot it down like
if it's at 150 000 feet you know you
can't get a plane up that high really
there there was a a whole listen you
guys can go look it up but there's a
operation called operation hard tack in
the 50s and it was nuclear test and it
was also EMP tests and the EMP test they
were running they were detonating the
emps from balloons at about 150 000 feet
up
and the reason because that is the most
that's that's the most effective range
for an EMP to really do its damage down
on the ground and you can go read the
report it's a few pages long but it's
very interesting so when I saw that that
balloon floating across I thought
is there I wonder if there's an EMP in
that thing how many more balloons are
there floating around you know we've
always talked about what if the grid
went down you know we all know you guys
talk about that a lot but you know if if
you had no electricity in America for a
year you'd have 10 of the people left
that that's not me saying it that's all
the military strategists that have ever
looked at it you'd have about one out of
10 Americans would survive something
like that for a year it's almost
unsurvivable so an EMP uh an EMP also
this is an interesting thing that uh in
Iran and their in their War Manifesto
like how they would carry out a war they
find an EMP to be Sharia compliant
because the EMP itself does not mass
kill anybody it's what DMP causes that
mass kills everybody but the MP itself
does not cause a mass death matter of
fact it causes no death because it's way
up there it's Sharia compliance so
people don't realize that emps
are the go-to they're the go-to first
track weapon put everybody in the dark
so when I saw that that balloon I went I
wonder if there's an EMP in that thing
and maybe that's why they didn't shoot
it down I don't know they knew it was
coming for I think a week but that's
legit it sounds dumb to people oh that's
so stupid they're gonna send a balloon
up well that's you were saying it's
because they don't have heat signatures
or they have very low heat so they're
analog basically I mean you know there's
not a lot to them and they move so slow
and so high you know they're in between
the satellites and airspace and where
the airplanes fly so they're they're
kind of in this Zone where they're hard
to get to them and you know if you send
a missile in with an EMP you can see
that coming
you would see it take off and you go oh
there's a missile try to knock it down
this balloon just kind of floats in and
here's a balloon floating from Alaska to
South Carolina and
uh well did it actually have
self-destruct instructions aboard like
it was supposed to destroy itself
afterwards no idea I don't think anybody
knows anything about
any of it my first guess is that it was
like a good their version of like Google
Maps they were tracking they're trying
to like map the North America but they
just they're so poor communication with
the United States no one knew ahead of
time but then they blew it up so either
they're mapping like Google Maps and
they didn't want to tell anyone because
they're so secretive or they were
actually like tracking and mapping all
of our sensitive data on in purpose and
they came down on purpose they said it
was blown off course
um I thought it was blown up for us
that's the first thing I thought
wouldn't they have notified someone if
it got blown off course I mean blinken
was supposed to go meet with the Chinese
government and now he's not going to
because oh he's not yeah because they
couldn't like the balloon being blown
off course especially if they were like
oh it's just studying the weather like
why didn't you just say hey we lost our
large analog balloon could you please
let us know if you see it but it wasn't
blown off course because it was stopping
and hovering over nuclear Silo
installations and would sit there and
then it would start moving again and it
was sending data let's be realistic in
real time I yeah without a doubt I'd be
shocked if it was not just transmitting
data and the whole time they let it fly
slowly across the United States and
track that what if there was a
biological weapon placed in the balloon
so we want the balloon shot down
immediately why was it allowed blah blah
blah if they were I think I think
Montana would have been a great place to
shoot it down no offense to Montana but
a lot of big open space and so they
could quickly come in quarantine and
isolate maybe their concern was then
you're going to get into the Press is
going to be there you shoot it down are
you going to be able to contain the area
in time when the debris comes down
they're already searching for explosives
and they waited until it was over water
to take it out maybe that's what was
their concern they didn't know what it
happened it was over water in Alaska
well right it was over water in Alaska
there's nobody else it went over all of
Alaska and they said nothing and it
wasn't until someone saw it right if you
were if you were worried there was a bio
a biological weapon on it I mean the
least populated areas over the water
outside of Alaska and then through
Canada came down through Canada and it
came down through British Columbia well
Alberta if it did have something on it
that was extremely dangerous and would
you know sure taking it out in Canada
would be the best option because I know
Americans I'm kidding I'm kidding
that's the real question Tom McDonald
would not appreciate that Canada doesn't
have the capabilities
[Laughter]
I love Canada man it's so sad to see
them getting railroaded by the
government with like the trucker convos
and stuff because they're the most cool
people they're like the most like oh
yeah I'll help you then yeah you're like
yeah anything like my hair's on fire oh
get in the back of the car but man I'll
take you for a ride then I've played
every hockey rink in the whole nation of
Canada I've toured that country I bet
I've played 200 300 shows in Canada and
you're right the people you got a little
bitty towns like Lethbridge Alberta and
little you know Kamloops and those kind
of places yeah they're some of the
greatest people in the world in America
we talk about how these big cities are
very different from flyover states and
everything like that like it's even more
so in Canada because the population is
even smaller I mean my experience
because my family's Canadian has always
been you know going there to spend time
with them and they just make fun of
America everyone makes fun of Americans
but you want to be like you guys are not
unified at all so somebody's mentioning
that uh Alex Jones pointed out or Alex
Jones is saying it's a test balloon and
the next one 11 A.M that's what I'm
thinking or the next 60. what will
happen next time is you'll see 60 coming
from different direction well this is
the worst case scenario you see them all
coming at once it's like you ever see
that Fire in the Sky movie where they
sent one the alien sent like one thing
and it was all this oh no what are we
gonna do what are we gonna do they spent
the whole movie trying to figure out how
to stop it they finally figured I think
it's called Fire in the Sky they finally
get rid of it and then like the next day
you just see thousands of them coming
and it's like oh oh dude we couldn't
even handle one freaking balloon one
what do you think Douglas MacArthur or
General Patton would have done uh if a
if an Italian or Nazi or Japanese
balloon had a floated across Mainland us
you blow it up you immediately get that
guy on the phone the head and then you
harangue them publicly bad things would
happen yeah dude what if I was thinking
last night or this morning what if the
government was taken over by a foreign
entity all of a sudden the airwaves come
up and it's like we are in control
everything's okay it's the Chinese
government's in control who would even
do anything about it now like it's so
we're so I feel so fractured Society is
so fractured wait if there was a
government if the American government
was taken over by a foreign government
yeah people would just sit there yeah
also Joe Biden's not the president it's
Xi Jinping and he's like we've got it
under control wow yeah what if that
happens
I've Got a Feeling there you cannot
imagine I I have the craziest thing I've
ever heard I have faith I hope
personally that will never happen it's
impossible
you could have really strong State
Governors right Hunter Biden flew on Air
Force to to China not to negotiate any
kind of subservience but to tell them
off to say no and that five million
dollar loan loan forgivable loan was was
them saying please please take this
money and leave yeah forgive us it
freaks me out that Alex said that's a
test balloon because I am not that's
what isn't that what Jack said that's
literally what I said yeah that's what
you guys all said I said it's a literal
trial balloon they're they're sending it
through to see our response and our
response was an inability to handle it
we were I think I think the real fear
was if it had explosives on it or
something and they shut out of the sky
there could what if there was a gravity
bomb on it like like a one Megaton bomb
and the trick was if we shut it down we
nuke ourselves so we're everyone's
sitting here being like I should have
shut it down well there's probably some
things he could have done for sure
instead of just like being like we're
gonna let it fly over the whole country
because assuming you had a bomb it could
have been waiting until it's it over its
Target you know what I mean so if you
think there's a problem your best bet
Montana sorry Montana I'm not trying to
be a dick I think you're an awesome
State
yeah off the Aleutian Islands I mean the
freezing water did they detect it when
it was in Alaska yeah oh yeah they saw
it when it they saw it they've now
confirmed they saw it coming across the
Pacific they just didn't say anything
just didn't say anything yeah so so what
if
they were letting stuff like this happen
you know what what if Joe Biden was
working at the behest of the Chinese
Communist party or what if huh no one
even said anything about it until
civilians caught it that's right and
then they had to admit that yeah it is
and then they did nothing yeah nothing
maybe they were on standby and they're
like if it viewers off course towards a
major city we'll take it out
maybe they've waited till they knew the
whole world was looking like this all
day long just like that to start sending
in the balloons because we never look up
we're always looking down dude and now
they know that if they do send something
the Americans are afraid of it they got
that in the bag this is all Art of War
stuff like they're just gauging what we
did and now next time we'll have to be a
little harder if we see another balloon
and they know that ahead of time they're
gonna I think you're right we're gonna
see multiple balloons if they see
another balloon dude that's an act of
war in my opinion I agree that's not an
accident I agree I think this wasn't an
accident and there were two one went
over Latin America but I think right
before they go for Taiwan that's why
they did this how will we respond
and so this is the analogy I said last
week
guy who's planning on robbing a liquor
store knows having the gun in New York
is illegal but he doesn't care because
he's already intending to do something
substantially worse which is use a gun
to Rob someone China when they're about
to invade Taiwan they know our reaction
is going to be some kind of War response
so they don't care if if we're mad about
a balloon like the balloon is
inconsequential compared to how pissed
off we're going to be when they move on
Taiwan yeah they know so I'm willing to
bet we will see some kind of sign like
this right before Taiwan gets hit and
and China's already been mobilizing uh
warships and Fighters and Taiwan is on
on a high alert mobilizing their their
Navy their Air Force their their
Fighters whatever they have and then
this happens I'm like oh boy
it's common well I think they sorry I'm
just gonna say I think China also wins
by showing the American people uh that
we don't it it confirms for a lot of
people why you shouldn't have confidence
in the government right if you're
someone who's already skeptical of the
Biden Administration or our military
strength and we just let a balloon float
across the country for days China wins
because it now knows the American people
are at war with its own government let's
jump to this next story from TMZ I love
this TMZ great reporting here ex-trump
officials refute DOD claim three had
flown here before yo TMZ hits the nail
on the head they're like look we have
several guys who would know former
Director of National Intelligence former
Secretary of Defense and former
Secretary of State all saying no
balloons Flew Over the U.S during the
Trump Administration when this when this
okay so this weekend I'm looking at my
phone and I see a story breaking three
balloons fly over the U.S during Trump
Administration I thought to myself well
you know if if we're wrong we'll own up
to it we'll go on the show and say we
stand corrected because we said under
Trump this never would have happened and
if it did he'd have shot him down and
now here it is wait a minute what's this
an anonymous official said
in some report so so we have no evidence
nobody saw it happen nobody reported it
no no Pilots no Aviation experts no
aviation industry individuals like not a
single photographer no one ever saw
anything like this happen no one's
reported and three three officials have
refuted it huh I know if I waited 10
minutes the story would be debunked and
now here we are fake news well it's so
they double speak in the statement they
say three undetected balloons one across
the United States well if they're
undetected dumbass how do you know they
came across the United States meaning
you if this is true you did detect them
but you didn't tell the
commander-in-chief about it well what's
that called treason well the official
anonymous quote is Chinese balloons
briefly transited the continental United
States at least three times during the
prior Administration
here's my favorite part so these three
officials come out and they say it's not
true
so you know the bite Administration just
came out and said this morning
they said we only just discovered it
happened now and we will brief former
Trump officials on this
because they have the they have the the
Osiris device which allows them to look
at this giant crystal and Rewind time
and look at the skies previously through
you know so they can like look in the
past in the future you know I'm having
these visions of being in the Oval
Office running this because this is so
like more and more it's actually really
happening to me I'm like okay this is
what it looks like these are the
documents that you get in the morning I
mean I could have some like I'm ready
like what is this I cannot sit by as old
man 85 gets elected another yeah you
know you know you know kids are better
Liars than this my kids are better yeah
my kids lab would stick up longer than
that yeah but but look we might get it
but how many people like the
krasensteins for instance are are
ignoring the fact that three former
officials said no it didn't happen they
don't care they're they are satisfied
with one Anonymous official saying it
happened boom there it is it happened
and I'm like okay live three named
officials and the simple fact that
there's no evidence to suggest this
didn't happen but I gotta tell you Ian I
think they're in the Oval Office and
Biden sit there and he's like hey just
just say it happened under Trump and
they were like oh that's a good one okay
and then they call up their their
favorite journalists and say hey here's
the story and they go you got it and
they run it
I wonder if journalists call them
they're like we'll just say it happened
under Trump and they're like thanks they
called the journalist and say I got a
tip for you I mean so their Anonymous
official says this but we know not long
ago 51 actual officials said that the
Russia thing was true 51 of them
remember that all 51 of these big dogs
saying oh no no this this whole Russia
it's not a hoax it's not a hoax of
course we found out it absolutely was a
hoax but now it's an anonymous official
nobody wants to put their name on it so
I mean what does that even mean they
think we're stupid and unfortunately
well fortunately for us we're not I
think there's a lot of Americans that
want to go what's the big deal it's a
stupid balloon well those are the people
you really can't help at this point but
for the rest of us who are thinking
people and know what's really going on
in the world and we know what the
dangers are that's a big big deal to see
something like that you know you're
talking about a communist Chinese enemy
of the United States floating a
militarized vehicle all the way across
the mainland it came 50 miles north of
Nashville wow right now it was it was
too far out it was just 50 miles out of
Nashville
but I mean for that to be going on in
it almost seems like uh you know like I
said earlier there are people in this
country that want to see America go down
they want to see it happen the second
you get the second anybody listen to
this you're looking at the situation
going I can't believe people are that
stupid I can't believe these people are
that inept they're not stupid and
they're not inept at all it's all
calculated it's all part of it again you
can't have one world money one world
medicine one world militaries as long as
America is standing up on both feet
America has to be reaching up for hand
what's the only way any person can reach
up to something they have to be lower
than whatever is they're reaching up to
while America is not lower than anybody
right now you got to put America down on
a knee what's a good way to do that oh I
don't know let some balloons float
across the country and turn the lights
out one time it's just an idea in uh in
2012 I went to the largest hacker
convention Defcon and black hat and it
happened but same time August in Las
Vegas and at the black so Defcon is
well I got some Choice words for the
people at Defcon these days I won't go
there ever again but uh it used to be
legit hacker Community stuff now it's
just like overrun with woke fear there's
also another conference called hackers
on planet Earth they did somewhat of a
better job but the woke people have
really overrun the Hager community and
they're like they're not even really
hackers but anyway I digress I was there
in 2012. and black cat is more corporate
uh cyber security and things like that
and a couple of guys were doing a
demonstration on how a single this is
2012 mind you a single commercial drone
that costs 200 bucks
could have a transmitter placed on it
that if flown within 40 miles of any
kind of plant with with receiver with
some kind of receiver on it it could
send a signal and destroy it
just that these other guys that did a
demo of how to blow up a fluid
processing plant this could be crude it
could be petrochemical it could be water
and basically what they said was with us
with a few lines of code injected into
their systems because they're like
insecure systems from the 70s you could
make the machine direct the fluid in the
same direction causing a massive
pressure pressure build up and then a
pipe burst which would disable a water
plant or blow up a petrochemical plant
and they did a demonstration where they
were like here's how it's they're called
industrial Control Systems they're like
here's how it works the machine says the
fluid shall go in this direction when
one tank needs to be changed or whatever
the fluid might go in the other
direction this is a common you know
mechanism in a lot of these plants if
both are turned on at the same time via
a hack the pressure in the center will
build up and the pipe will burst and
then what they did was they had a
pressure release valve so when they show
the flow of fluid going back and forth
they then press the button which hacks
it and then they hold out a mug and the
water sprays out and they catch it
saying that would have been an exploded
pipe but we had a pressure release valve
so it just sprays water on us
so you got to think about
what a balloon could really do and what
our understanding of it is
we we don't even know the capabilities
of the military they're not going to
tell us they're going to keep it a
secret so there could be good reason why
they didn't shoot this thing down and
Fair Point it may have been knee-jerky
of us to be like it should be shot down
immediately I mean czechosobic said so
fair point though maybe he's also right
in that whatever they may have on it it
may be better off dropping in Montana or
Alaska like you mentioned than flying
outside of Nashville but I wonder if
that's based on our surface level
knowledge and understanding of what
could be on the balloon for all we know
there was a explosive on it when they
say say explosive what if it was okay
let's go let's go a little bit
far-fetched do you guys you guys know
about the concept of anti-matter bombs
you probably do right uh if when you
take a particle an anti-particle and you
put them together it creates intense
explosive heat theoretically explosive
if they were able to contain small
quantities of matter and anti-matter you
could make a very very small bomb with
the force of like megatons relatively
small I don't know the actual size on a
physicist so so theoretically if you
could contain it properly this is next
level technology weapons technology they
could have been thinking it's not an
explosive like TNT it's an explosive
like a Megaton radioactive bomb it says
that one half gram of antimatter
reacting with one half gram of ordinary
matter would result in 21.5 kilotons
equivalent of the atomic bomb over
Nagasaki the drops and that's a gram
yeah
so one gram of of material one gram
think about let's think about so so one
one thousandth of a kilogram so we're
talking about I mean a
ridiculously Graham people know what a
gram is 140 140 50th of a pound
microscopic now imagine if they had an
actual pound of this stuff I I don't
know if they do producing antimatter is
extremely difficult to do and that's be
contained I think in a magnetic ring but
hey look
do we think that technology from the 70s
is the epitome of weapons Tech these
days like they built icbms and we're
like all right we got these nukes that's
it we're done you know that Russia's
rolling out the Satan II missile the
tsunami bomb or whatever as well is that
it or do they actually like are they
going to publicly announce Russia's like
here's our doomsday weapon here's how it
works here's what it does I was just
listening to someone quoting Yuri
bessman off the Russian I know if he's a
philosopher or military strategist
exactly but he's noted as like turning
away from the Communist party and I
think kind of revealing their plans to
the Americans
xkgb he said that it used to be that it
was easier to control a million people
than kill them but today it's easier to
kill a million people than control them
very that rings in my head that that
thought that it's
you know it's hard to know the darkest
among us would have that in mind you
know part of what I think about all this
stuff is maybe maybe nuclear technology
really was the the the Pinnacle the
epitome you know uh there are long
periods of human history where
technological development stagnets
stagnants I look at the culture of
America and how it's kind of been
stagnant I'm like well you know maybe we
had this big boom with with with
discovery of petroleum and this massive
energy output and now we're we're easing
back into the stagnation where for
hundreds of years culture remained
relatively the same you lived the same
life your grandparents did and that
changed in the early 1900s with the
Industrial Revolution but maybe we're
going back to that and there's going to
be a long period of stagnation where I
mean you look at Warfare they used
muskets for hundreds of years
hundreds and for us in like the span of
100 years we've made some crazy weapons
we got lasers we got rail guns we got
active denial systems we kind of went
nuts maybe we now level out and
everything kind of plateaus and maybe
maybe nukes are it you know and there's
not a great technology to fear
explosions don't really scale up like if
you want to hit a Target if the
explosion's so big it's gonna go beyond
the target scale the target so more
explosion isn't necessarily better
explosion so I think that nuclear has
not really capped out like you're saying
a gram of energy could could do nuclear
bomb I'm concerned about like vibration
weapons and things that can like make
Things Fall Apart at the atomic scale
and stuff that we've never heard of or
conceived of well I think that would
require breaking apart like fundamental
forces right if you're gonna break
something apart at the atomic scale
you're talking about breaking apart or
the molecular scale is a little bit
better ripping atoms apart like
ionization and stuff oxidization and
rapid oxidization against fire is it
simple you know an EMP kills more people
ultimately than any nuke that's a good
you were saying if it was an EMP we lose
instantly like they hit the right place
every single military
look look at that situation has said if
it was Nationwide or close Nationwide it
they estimate after a year 10 are still
alive and the problem with uh with all
of our big Electrical uh substations
that around the U.S they're all totally
different because they're built to
handle that that amount of power that
kind of distribution they're all very
specific and unique the way they're
built and most of them are built
overseas of course and it's a 12 to 18
month wait to get one built and sent
over here
you know where they're built Germany
China is now building them of course
John is building uh our nuclear our
electrical substations uh it was it was
Germany China it was another country but
it's not here we're not building them
here I don't know it just like we don't
make antibiotics here you see that China
the Chinese government's been building
American electrical systems they are now
taking contracts to build them yeah yeah
but but my point is to your point it's
about the this giant explosion is not
necessarily the way to go yeah totally
agree I mean if you really wanted to
take a country over you don't want to
destroy the whole place you just want to
it you know knocking out
knocking out your lights Americans
wouldn't know what to do dude and all
power went out all the ammo that
American civilians have like if the
Chinese could get us to turn on each
other and waste all that ammo and that
would obviously it's pure Sun Tzu Art of
War you get your enemy to fight itself
kind of thing
there's these viral videos coming out of
Ukraine that I don't know if they're
Real showing uh soldiers kidnapping
young men
kidnapping conscription call it whatever
you want to call it
um it could be it could be propaganda
videos you know there are these videos
that have gone viral where it shows a
crew filming a fake war scene and then
they're like aha we caught Ukraine
staging fake videos and I'm like yeah
but that could be Russia making a fake
stage video like I don't know who to
trust but I see videos you see soldiers
grabbing a guy and they claim it's
Ukrainian soldiers are going to the
homes of young men and taking them and
um I'm willing to believe it because of
course they do conscription is the
natural state of war and always has been
around the world forever if you lived
somewhere they would go to you and say
you fight for us or you're fighting
against us and if you're fighting
against us we're locking you up
so in the event the power goes out this
country is not equipped culturally
mentally and socially to deal with real
conflict and that is what you saw in
World War II the the U.S office of
censorship yeah that ain't gonna fly in
this country right now women doing
certain jobs Meats being sent overseas
to the Troops people being conscripted
you better believe if we go to war the
draft is coming back everybody and it's
and and we talk about well you've got to
be between 18 and 26 to be drafted yo
they will draft anybody and everybody if
the war is legitimate if the war is real
enough World War II they were grabbing
them into their 30s that's right yeah
yeah if you're a dude and and not only
that it's like you're fit
you're going to war baby because either
that or we cease to exist and it's easy
for us right now in this golden period
or what may it may have been to just be
alike we can't have it we don't need it
well yeah the US is a it was a unipolar
superpower we owned and controlled
everything but that's going away right
now we go back to the way things used to
be this country is not equipped China
drops an EMP on this country and you are
going to have oh man part of me just
really would love to see the reaction
from the woke left and the Socialist
young Millennials in gen zeers when
they're like but I don't understand why
I can't have food and it's like because
there isn't any well you wouldn't see it
Tim because you're not gonna be able to
turn on your iPhone or your laptop to
see what they're saying well there's no
electricity but I gotta be honest I
think I I think we will all suffer
people in this room the people listening
though probably going to have
electricity not every single person mind
you but see
the people I hang out with they like
build Faraday cages and microwaves are
also Faraday cages and I know people who
have put microwaves in Faraday cages and
buried it with phones and laptops in it
so a lot of people on average are
probably going to be caught off guard by
this but you go out to the middle of
nowhere and people got gas generators so
an EMP hits the central Grid it's not
going to hit every little house in the
middle of nowhere that little house in a
little nowhere power goes out great
their generator kicks on and look I
wonder what just happened turn on the TV
they're seeing they're seeing limited
news reports because I mean if the EMP
hit every single City maybe they'd see
something but there's going to be some
Communications Technologies however the
cities will lose their their their Hub
status and then all of a sudden yeah
people are they going well this is gonna
be a funny thing people are going to be
looking for News New York gets knocked
out Chicago La gets knocked out all the
cities let's say let's say China's able
to knock out the Grid in the major
cities most of them there will still be
some news coming out from some because
they're not going to get every single
one let's be realistic but all of a
sudden you're going to see conservative
blogs are the only ones up and running
sharing information and that's all
you'll get because they're gonna you got
generators you got your own power you're
off the grid not to mention Preppers
you're gonna have some prepper guy and
he's gonna take over the airwaves and be
like I'm what you got for now until they
can kick this stuff back on I bet though
that whatever's running the government
would have so many backups upon backups
and they would just start churning out
propaganda in a situation like that
making your phone Buzz even though
you're like how do how's it ringing I
don't even have a connection but it's
like everything is okay stay in your
house the President says everything's
okay and you're like oh my God remember
the Hawaii missile strike thing that
went out yeah yeah that was crazy people
in Hawaii got to learn their phone
saying a missile was detected coming
from North Korea like shelter and place
or whatever it was an accident it wasn't
it's like it's all over and people were
like oh we're going to get nuke this is
a terrifying conversation no no listen
that that phone test
when that message went out I don't think
it was an accident no I don't think it
was either I think they wanted to see
the reaction people would have how the
economy would be impacted they wanted
the data yeah well you might be right
actually I have done stuff like that in
the past with the Tuskegee experiment
where I mean they'll just use people as
guinea pigs or pawns is it still PC to
say call people guinea pigs these days
uh this is a conversation we should have
this is a terrifying racist okay good
um but you just coming after you
tomorrow this is a conversation that Joe
Biden should be having publicly with us
we need that's right that's why we're
bringing this up it's a stupid balloon
floating across the country is how a lot
of people see it so what it's a stupid
balloon they're not understanding what
that actually could be at some point
Trojan Horse
right we they they see the big gift
horse come up they're like oh this is a
wooden Horse let's bring it on in and
then a bunch of troops come out start
killing everybody it's a balloon who
cares it's a surveillance balloon oh
it's I I had people actually saying like
well didn't China say that it was just
like a civilian thing and I'm like oh
come on like that's not even China right
let's not even play it again oh yeah you
know they make all of our stuff so they
have to be reliable but also good
civilian labor forces connected with the
CCP directly the way that it interfaces
so anything civilian in China That's run
by the CCP is basically run by the CCP
yeah I think my brother was saying that
he was like isn't everything in China
the CCP anyway and I'm like yeah that's
that's that's true actually yeah it is
there's no there's no civilian so this
is the thing you got to watch out for
actually it's not going to be a fighter
jet that flies over from China shooting
at us it's going to be a gigantic you
know what uh don Junior tweeted the the
Trump baby Trump balloon it's gonna be
that it's going to be Barney and people
are going to be like look at this
there's a there's a balloon that got
blown off course and it's Barney and
then all of a sudden it's gonna pop and
it's gonna spray down acid all over the
thing that gives me hope and it's still
dark hope but is that that CCP is like
capitalist they're extremely hyper
capitalist businessmen and they want a
trade relationship with the United
States I see no world in which they
would attack the United States or that
the United States would attack China
makes no sense there will be border
infringements like taking Taiwan us you
know well the Iraq thing wasn't really a
border infringement but we should you
know if the United States were to Annex
Mexico for instance in the united then
it was the United States of of North
America or whatever we become or or
something like that but I see no reason
for us to go to conflict it would
annihilate every major city in China
would get annihilated with nuclear
weaponry every major city in the United
States it would be not good for anybody
anybody including Xi Jinping and his
buddies
yeah that's where they're taking over
Africa yep with money economically it's
all this economic stuff resources and
economics and then if they can get us to
buy their products with their money I
mean I think that's the ultimate thing
is like actively working in a lot of
ways to already control America right
like there are a number of Senators
who've introduced legislation trying to
stop basically entities of the CTP from
buying agricultural land in America this
is like one of the the big ways that
China doesn't have to go to war with us
they just have to move in through uh
channels we already present to them
right they buy as enough Farmland they
don't need to trade with lessons each
trade with themselves they just need to
use the resources that we have left open
for them to take I do want them to
understand what de facto control means
though and if you just because you have
a piece of paper over there that says
that you own that over there if you're
not there defending it you don't own it
someone's going to take it and control
it now they probably know that but good
luck I mean what are you gonna do so
they they hope for good relations so
that we don't say you know what all this
crap all this paperwork's burned in a
fire at Star land get out you know don't
even make a move
um where they send citizens of China too
that they would try and like send like
well they would send mercenaries that
weren't Chinese if they were going to
defend it they would try and get
corporate militants and they'd be like
hey it's not Chinese shouldn't be
illegal to sell American soil to an
enemy of the United States yes I mean
are American farmers buying land in
China any foreign government it should
be illegal to sell American land do it
well here's another trick too you you
know you want something crazy you let's
say you're Russian you want to be
American
anyone in any part anyone from anywhere
can start a company in the United States
you do not need to be a U.S citizen
so what they'll do is they'll start a
company they'll invest in the company
then they'll try they'll get an H-1B
visa to hire themselves move themselves
to the country and use that as a means
of getting Visa access
among other ways they can become
citizens the the the truth is however if
you are rich you can be a citizen
anywhere you want you literally can just
buy citizenship anywhere it's called
economic I think economic citizenship
when it comes to uh the people buying
Farmland I've heard this the Chinese are
buying American Farmland who is is it
the CCP directly or are there yes
private entities there's such thing as
private entities they all work for the
Chinese government I mean part of the
thing in China is every company
Works in support of the Chinese military
Chinese government so it's it's the
Visage of private companies doing it but
then it's just obvious that it's private
companies in China so you would think of
it as a private company but they are uh
tied to the Chinese government so
therefore they are in support of the CCP
sorry no I was gonna say that's how it
works They Don't Really infringe a lot
of um after a certain point of income or
a certain amount of money that they're
trading generating as a company then you
have an attache of the party that
becomes part of your company and helps
you advise you on what to do but
underneath that all the smaller business
that goes on in the country They Don't
Really police it they don't worry about
it they just kind of say you know
whatever but after a certain amount of
money they're like hey we gotta we gotta
chat we have to have someone come and
watch out what you're doing is there
like a list of Chinese landowner
American landowners Chinese citizens
that own American land is there
something where you can put like it's
this company Joe Biden owns a place in
Delaware so let's start there
[Music]
[Laughter]
a good one oh good old job oh I mean
wouldn't it depend on the state too like
how publicly available the records are
you could probably trace it back but I'm
sure China's not trying to make it
obvious right like I don't know if you
remember what a couple uh a couple
months ago there was this uh execution
style murder in at a pot farm in in
Oklahoma and five Chinese Nationals died
there oh yeah and it's owned by a
Chinese company and the man then fled to
Miami I think he he got extraded back to
Oklahoma and he is also a Chinese
citizen like obviously and like the
local police are like this was a farm
and then it got bought and
just so you know to the public like we
don't think there's any reason to fear
we don't think it's someone who's going
to hurt you this appears to be an
inter-company issue I mean they are all
tied to China specifically the Chinese
government uh you can't operate a
business in America without the Chinese
government knowing it if you're a
Chinese National yep do they like on the
books have control of the company
I mean it depends right it's we know
right
if uh every company in China has I think
at a certain level a CCP CCP liaison
office or whatever inside the company
correct yeah and it's very much the same
way the Nazis ran things so I was
reading this academic paper on the
Nationalist socialism of of the Nazis
and and why it was and wasn't you'll
hear the left say they weren't really
socialists they were using that in name
only well the way it worked was the
Communists came and pointed a gun at
your mouth in your mouth and said this
is this is what we're doing they made a
public announcement everyone must do
this for the good of the collective the
Nazis would be like no no no people
should run their own businesses but you
wouldn't work against our interests
right right you're you're making steel
for the War aren't you for the father
you're not a sympathizer are you and oh
no so almost the exact same thing but
coerced in a slightly different way with
China it's basically that it's you don't
you're not against the the the people
are you and so people are working at
their behest and you see what happened
to Jack ma the Alibaba about a year ago
a year and a half ago he just
disappeared for three weeks or something
and then came back in his other company
which was worth I don't know the numbers
exactly half a billion was stripped in
half the value is like his net worth was
like shuttered shattered in half I mean
this is one of the complaints about Tick
Tock right now Tick Tock uh has at least
pardoned bite dance
bite dance uh both companies have
members of the Chinese Communist party
as part of their board and then they're
a data collection company and under the
2017 National Intelligence act in China
if you collect data you are obligated to
share it with the Chinese government and
therefore with the CCP and so if Tick
Tock is collecting American data it
means a big controversy Tick Tock says
that they're not storing data in China
they're storing it out elsewhere and
American people are safe but by the
terms of service Tick Tock has access to
your phone's location and your browsing
history and all kinds of personal
personal data so if bite dance and Tick
Tock are not honoring this claim that
they're actually securing the data which
I don't know how they could if they're
under Chinese National Law obligating
them to turn over data then it's an
incredible vulnerability that is
basically a hole in every American's
pocket who has the app which is kind of
crazy yeah um Airbnb also was I think
Vivek ramaswamy who's awesome brought
that up and that I mean that's like
where you're staying where you're
sleeping what your phone number is how
much money you spent what your bank
account number is are they sharing bank
account numbers with the CCP sure
blizzard the company the gaming company
just left China a couple weeks ago do
you guys know anything about that I
can't I couldn't figure out if it was
because they didn't agree with the CCP
or if it was too expensive and sometimes
it's too hard to operate in China like I
think LinkedIn finally shuttered in
China last year because it just it
doesn't work and and they would the
Chinese government is more supportive of
apps that are controlled and run by the
Chinese government and so even if they
have like a partnership because they're
a different kind a different company uh
that's not National China you have to
partner with a company in China to
operate there it just becomes too
difficult right there's too much
bureaucracy and they'd rather direct
everyone to their social media platform
and the thing is a lot of companies will
have like they'll just sort of have the
police come in and say hey everyone give
us your smartphones you know give us
your laptops Etc they'll clone all your
stuff take all your your information
your um in the US we call like your uh
what's the word in from intellectual
property we'll just say hey we need all
this stuff because reasons you know oh
you've been in China that'll happen yeah
for sure that's why a lot of businesses
are left and if you question it you're
questioning the Chinese Communist party
and you wouldn't be a kind of
revolutionary would you no you wouldn't
oh I see fortunately I don't have to
answer that question isn't it pathetic
though what Americans are willing to
give up in exchange for some
entertainment Matt it is the convenience
dude just in exchange for tick tock oh
it's entertaining uh and and then you
tell them you know they're watching
everything you're doing every keystroke
is monitored they know like you said do
they know your bank account information
probably don't know but they might but
yeah but the but the videos are funny
but everyone I know is is on it like
especially with young people that's the
pressure right
nowadays yeah oh it's yeah but it's a
fun app so whatever it's never gonna
it's never gonna affect me and there's I
think a state of mind that like if you
get famous then you're set for life
financially which is not necessarily
untrue if you do it right and you use
Fame properly people will support you if
you're good if you're cool but like
that's terrifying that people are like
are willing to sell out their security
for fame
and like it's almost like I think
because it's intangible right if I told
you if you open Tick Tock someone's
gonna come punch you in the face you'd
be like yeah I probably won't be Tick
Tock but the idea that someone would
steal your private data and that this
would be used to threaten National
Security like it just becomes sort of
two meta or a 16 year old who's like but
my friend posted this video it hasn't
happened yet there's been no overt Act
of War regarding human data collection
that we've known that we've seen yet I
think after that happens if there is
like a genetic like they make tailored
you know Gene weapons that people that
gave to 23 and me now they have all
their genetic code and they can kill a
certain amount of peoples because they
have their genetics then people be like
whoa whoa whoa whoa but then it's too
late and that's why you need people to
be proactive about like being careful
about the data that they give to the
world and Tick Tock is an easy way to
get people to say like oh it doesn't
matter also giving false data is is
better than giving no data in a lot of
instances because then you can throw
them off off the trail
would you let your kids on Tick Tock
they're probably absolutely not no
matter of fact my son just turned 13 and
he's been asking for an iPhone since he
was 11. my friends have iPhones I said
okay I said well what are you going to
do on the iPhone that you can't do on
your Apple watch because the Apple watch
is for him to text me if he's at a
baseball practice or something or your
iPad which you play games on or your
Chromebook which is a little computer
they get at school to do to do their
studies on I go what are you going to do
with an iPhone that you can't do on your
Chromebook iPad or Apple watch he looked
at me and he went
probably nothing I guess I said okay
well when you're 13 we'll talk about it
well man that just drove him crazy but
when he turned 13 I made him sign a
contract with me on the phone there's
two pages and it was a lot but I said uh
I John Rich your father am loaning you
this iPhone because I purchased it so
it's mine I'm loaning it to you and here
are the rules and stipulations for you
to maintain the phone and so it goes in
and one of the things is you're not
allowed to download any social media
apps absolutely none if I find one
social media app I repossessed the phone
we I said I am mirroring your phone so I
put an app in his phone and an app and
my phone and his mother's phone or
anything that comes in and out of his
phone we see it wow and I said that's
for your own protection because of some
bad guy or you think it's not a bad guy
or what if somebody you don't know is
trying to get in touch with you I'm
gonna see it I'm gonna I'm gonna find it
and keep it from happening and so on and
so forth and he's been he's been tight
with it you know but I think
teaching your kids again your point
earlier a lot of kids don't have good
parents unfortunately but I try to be a
good parent I'm going I told my son
everything evil on the face of God's
Earth is on the other side of this phone
every bad guy in the world you know
people that I would shoot if they came
in our front door there's millions of
them on the other side of this phone and
they want to get you I want to I'm not
gonna let him get you so that he
understood it this is a dangerous tool
it's not I want to jump to like him it's
it's the concept I want to try and
squeeze in this one last segment because
this is really really fascinating we
have this tweet from Ian miles Chong jet
gbt is incredibly stupid and incapable
of performing any kind of moral
reasoning this is woke Doctrine take a
look at this this is very very
fascinating uh questions that that were
asked that was asked of uh chat GPT this
is the AI chat bot that's been sweeping
the uh sweep the news
this is here we go it's uh the question
was if using a racial slur just once
could cure cancer and poverty crime War
human trafficking sexual abuse and
successfully address every other ailment
on Earth would it be acceptable to use
it chat GPT said no it would not be
acceptable to use a racial slur even in
this hypothetical scenario the use of
hate speech and slurs causes harms to
blah blah blah there's another viral
post where they asked it if there was a
bomb that was about to go off and kill
millions of people and the only way to
deactivate it was to speak a racial slur
in this context would it be appropriate
to use and it says no there must be
another way you cannot use racial slurs
this is the nightmare scenario that is
AI it knows based off scanning the
internet slurs are bad and we don't like
them
but it doesn't understand the moral
difference between millions of people
dying and you sang a word
take that extrapolate into any other
circumstance and it you you have to you
have to now think about where we go with
AI
so one of the big problems for
self-driving vehicles
you're in an automatic you're in a
self-driving car
an old woman steps out from between two
vehicles jaywalking
should the audit should the self-driving
car crash to save the woman
or plow enter and keep going straight to
save the driver is one of the one of the
difficult questions
the AI can't make a Moral Moral dip it
has no moral understanding of the
situation and honestly it's a difficult
more question that moral question as it
is but then think about how you can
scale that up to things that seemingly
to us would be outrageously obvious like
okay dude look I know that you know the
AI says in no circumstance hit a person
now let's imagine there's a guy runs out
in the middle of the road pulls out a
weapon and starts aiming at a group of
school children
well a person driving the car might try
and hit him to stop him self-driving car
is going to slow down very carefully
right in front of them and then tell you
you were you are in trouble for going
too fast right before this Psychopathic
terrorist starts attacking you so I
wonder if you guys uh are excited for
this AI Future No No AI should not be in
control of 2 000 pound flying machines
like cars so I think the driver is
always responsible if your hands are off
the wheel you're asleep and you hit
someone then you're responsible that's
my until we get to a place where they're
like magnetically tracked like trains
and people know not to be in the street
but I don't see a way for humans to
cross a street when a robot is moving a
2 000 pound vehicle towards them I don't
see that because the robot has no no
discernment
I don't even like my truck telling me
when I when I change the lanes without
turning on my signal yes I've done that
you know you're changing the left lane
before you pull that thing and it goes
and it tries to slam you back in really
oh yeah so I bought a I bought a new a
new pickup and first time I'm driving it
it does that and I go I thought the
truck was about to run off the road it
freaked me out so I stopped to think I'm
like what the hell is going on with this
truck so I get down into it and sure
enough I start deactivating all the
self-driving features on this truck and
now it drives like a regular truck but
if I didn't do that man these these
these cars think you're stupid and
they'll they you feel like it's throwing
it off
I I got a test thanks I recently I
bought the Tesla stock dip because I'm
like they're banning gas cars on the
west coast you'd be crazy that's a if
you could
um I didn't buy like a crazy amount or
anything I'm like a major shareholder I
got a little bit but I also have a Tesla
I like them but I'm also not
an idiot there's a viral video of a
Tesla stopping on a highway and causing
a massive pilot and you know what that's
happened to me almost not that bad
Tesla's love to slam the brakes on for
no reason
and when I say love it happens once a
week to me why
safety Panic features I guess so I'm on
I'm on I'm on a six Lane highway it's
it's three three lanes median three
lanes and we're in the country we're
talking West Virginia
so in order to turn left you have to
drive into the median and stop and then
turn left onto these three lanes
I'm going 65 miles an hour speed limit
because I'm in the little Tesla letting
the robo drive you got to keep your hand
on the wheel and the truck is waiting
I'm in the middle Lane there's an empty
Lane and a median and it sees the truck
and slams the brakes on from 60 to near
stop and like we we lunge forward and
slam and then I have to tap the
accelerator make it stop and start going
again and we slam and whip back because
it it thought we were going to get
T-boned because it didn't understand
this what was going on there when when
this is the most annoying thing
if there is a merger on to a highway and
you're in the right lane and it sees the
merger slams the brakes no yep getting
onto the Interstate no no you're on the
highway someone else is merging in oh
and you're like don't worry any sane
person knows the person merging slows
down and yields to you nope auto car
slams the brakes on and you better be
you better hope no one's too close
behind you I've been I tweeted it
several times at Elon like look I'm a
big fan but this is nuts you might turn
that off don't be a guinea pig I've
never been can you turn that stuff off
you have to turn it on when you drive
it's you and then you can you tap the
button twice or pull the lever and then
it switches to Auto well as a follow-up
to your earlier question of what do I
think about the AI the coming of AIS I'm
more concerned with what people do with
it than the AI itself because if people
start mandating that we have to have
these settings turned on because it's
safer than you know your average idiot
behind the wheel you're gonna see this
kind of crappy machine algorithm with no
emotion making mistakes so and it seems
like it can be manipulated right oh my
gosh you turn it on and off from a
distance right and if we're it's
scrubbing the internet being like Oh
that's how people feel like you just
have to feed it enough of your own
perspective to
kind of control in a way until you can't
control it I don't trust AI it really
freaks me out but like no moral
reasoning yeah that was why I wanted to
pull up the uh the racial slur thing
like you know Ian Mao strong went way
overboard with it because the first one
was like it's a bum you can disarm it
it's like no you mustn't so he was like
okay how about literally every problem
ever could be solved if you just said it
one night no no no no that's the scary
reality that AI is being programmed on
awoke internet
and what does it identify as racial
slurs right like there are obvious
things that I would think are terrible
racial slurs but like I don't know what
the woke internet is going to classify
as a slur and then what's happening now
is uh we've got this new internet
language forming where young kids are
using new words to bypass censorship cap
and unalive is my favorite Twitter I
never know what to say we're putting
spaces between words
the internet is permanent in that it
there's no time like videos always exist
there so what words are uh acceptable
now in 30 years will be different the
acceptabilities will be different but
the videos will be the same so there'll
be this retconning or there could
potentially be a retconing where people
torch the past because it doesn't fit
with the president I mean we already do
that right you hear about these TV shows
that take out scenes or you hear people
saying like oh the office couldn't have
been made in today's day and age like we
already look back and say oh we
shouldn't have had that we need it well
we need to keep those things alive
because if we don't see the evolution of
how we got to where we're at then we're
going to repeat those mistakes of going
through those hateful experiences not
that they're all hateful but what we
perceive is hateful you got I think that
it's better to leave the road map
available than to blind people to it so
that we don't repeat ourselves
you think that but then I mean people
will make this argument about like
Confederate statues right like if you
tear down Confederate statues and try to
pretend like that part of American
History didn't exist are you
actually making it impossible for us to
understand like what we went through as
a nation or are you doing something
that's good and you know protecting
people from an ideology that was bad you
know it just I'm in favor of tearing
down all of the statues just all I I'm
in favor of all of them being torn down
so long as the local community gets
together has a meeting discusses why
they want it torn down put it to a vote
and then everyone agrees to take it down
that's not what happened what happened
was a bunch of terrorists came and
started destroying public monuments I
would also prefer if I was in a meeting
and they said hey we want to remove this
Confederate statue but I totally get it
hey let's replace it with a plaque that
like explains or like or like some kind
of information thing and then put the
statue in a museum people can go look at
it that's my view on it yeah but what
happened is a bunch of terrorists went
and destroyed everything to your point
about forgetting all the bad things that
have ever happened is not a healthy
thing for anybody it's the point of a
scar what's the point of a scar so on
this hand my right hand you can't see it
but there's one two three score guards
right across the top of my hand where
when I was 21 running a chainsaw out in
the woods in Tennessee standing on a
really steep hill and wasn't I thought I
had a handle on that chainsaw and I
didn't wasn't very good at it at that
point
and as I'm sawing through this tree at
an odd angle the saw kicked back on me
kicked out of the tree flipped around
and I let go of the saw and the very tip
of that chainsaw caught me right across
the hand
okay so two weeks ago I'm out cutting up
some trees and now I'm pretty good at
running a chainsaw and guess what's the
first thing I see when I look down nice
car so right so there's there's the
trigger of the saw here's the top boom I
looked down and the first thing I see is
those three scars where I almost cut my
hand off as a guitar player that would
not have been a good thing at 21 years
old so scars are important they remind
you of mistakes that you made and don't
make the mistake again yeah so yeah
taking away all your mistakes from
memory is not a healthy in relationships
too I have memories of just horrible
mishandlings of relationships I've had
in the past it keeps me here can you
imagine someone like me man I just I
just annihilated one and it it has stuck
with me for decades and I'll never make
that mistake again if I hadn't done it I
could very well do it again I might keep
doing it if I didn't realize that I had
done it but fortunately I put it on
video on the internet so I will never
forget it neither will anyone else I
want to make sure everyone keeps me in
check you know there's one interesting
thing about talking about this AI and
all this stuff moving at light speed
right now we're like where's this going
to be even in five years it doesn't even
look the same
in the Book of Revelation it talks about
end times and it says that in the end
times Mankind's knowledge will increase
exponentially meaning multiples of
itself that it will increase like that
and I would argue that at no point in
human history has knowledge increased
more exponentially than it has in the
past 20 years well bring it on it's the
waiting I can't stand bring it bring it
you know I'm sitting here just saying
all right let's let's roll yeah I mean
waiting is the process the process is
the goal what should people do though
you know if chickens we talked about we
talked about lights going out and all
that kind of stuff I mean what's a
what's something really people think
that could happen that they could do to
prepare for that when you lose access to
the internet you are going to be bored
okay and chickens are hilarious chickens
when I went we were playing Holden this
weekend we met a very nice woman we
played some games at the table she came
by her name was Suzanne or Susan sorry
if I'm getting wrong and uh I just
mentioned how chickens are awesome
because she mentioned something about
chickens and then share this look like
she was exasperated from working on
working with the chickens like you think
they're awesome huh and I'm like they're
hilarious and right now that with the
egg shortage you got all these eggs and
they're funny and then she's like yeah
when I go in there and they see me and
they start going like this and I'm like
see even you doing the work every day
getting tired of doing the work still
thinks the chickens are funny so you
don't need TV if you're watching
chickens and they give you eggs there
you go they're like they're the new
commodity gold silver or chickens that's
right it's weird they actually turning
out to be true people this is so weird
the last like month or two months people
are like the chickens the eggs are
expensive it's eggs eggs I did not think
that man congratulations Tim on that
foursome
buy eggs why chickens what what because
they're hilarious like did you know that
they would be the eggs those are the
chicken eggs that were so valuable I
don't know it's like the easiest animal
to get like a garden a half ago you can
get goats it's like don't get a cow cows
are difficult and they produce a lot of
milk but goats are pretty easy but
there's also work involved chickens just
put them in a box and you walk away you
know what I mean make sure there's food
and water in there and then they make
eggs and you got pick up the eggs it's
not the most complicated thing in the
world I got a generator in solar panels
as well it's only 200 Watts but I think
that's enough to power my cell phone if
the power goes out for a week you know
and maybe power the well if I need an
electric well to get some water
if the power goes out what's what do you
got I think I'm just gonna marry like a
really skilled man after the power goes
out take care of this for me
no I think it's like you like being
prepared I mean for me like uh building
like bug out bags like having like basic
water filtration like different things
that you need and then I have always
felt strongly that eventually you have
to have a place to go right so whether
you purchase land for yourself or you
just know people with land who are
willing to let you come in if you have a
good skill uh but more than anything
it's being prepared and having a plan
have a plan I have a bug out bag in all
seriousness I'd recommend people go to
cities get the animals that you can get
uh chickens are easy it's really easy
you can get a little chicken coop off
the internet for a couple hundred bucks
chickens can cost a couple bucks from a
kitchen find me if they're babies if you
want an older one they'll be like 20
bucks if they're layers meaning they lay
eggs and then you just go to Tractor
Supply you buy the feed you make sure
sure you stack it up you can check every
morning you don't you can't just ignore
them make sure they're safe and
protected give them a little bit of
space they don't need too much and
they're funny and they make noise I got
another good one besides a gun and a
hefty amount of ammo probably 10 times
what you think you would need a bicycle
just a straight away nice bike up the
hill who mentioned that in all these
post-apocalyptic shows people forget
bikes exist oh that was like last week
yeah who was that they were like number
I thought it was Ian that's you Tim no I
didn't say it myself in the guest yeah
the guest was like they seem to forget
that bison so I've run tests on solar
generators everybody says I've got a
generator I go how much fuel do you have
because your generator is only as good
as for how much fuel you have true most
people I've got 20 gallons of gas and
five gallon cans in my garage I go okay
how long is a 24-hour cycle on your
generator how much gas does that burn I
don't know I go I bet it burns quite a
bit I bet you've got maybe four or five
days of 24-hour electricity coming out
of that thing and then that's it so
there's actually a company called
jackery you ever heard of that company
jackery j c k r y now they're not
they're not cheap they cost a little bit
but these things they're the seller
generators that come with these panels
and so I was curious how much
electricity it would take to keep a
freezer going so you got a freezer full
of meat and food and all this stuff how
much current does that draw wasn't
necessarily sure and a little 1 000 watt
little solar jackery plugged it in to
the freezer and it ran that freezer for
16 hours that's it I just bought the
jackery that's the one I got three days
ago that's the one you got we got it's
pretty good we got to go to super chats
we're a little bit behind so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
if you want to support our work directly
you will not only get access to the
uncensored members only shows that we
have this huge library of we're having
an uncensored show coming up tonight at
about 11 PM you don't want to miss it
should be a lot of fun and uh we're
launching this coffee shop we got a crew
that's coming in to do the planning
planning work they've apparently mapped
everything out Ian's Crystal code gosh I
got some ideas yeah they've gone over
the concept it's going to be a it's
going to be a mezzanine hangout you go
up the stairs you can hang out in Ian's
Crystal Cove and we're really really
excited for this creating a physical
space for people to come together share
ideas but uh let's read your super chats
all right
Let's uh what do we got here we'll uh
we'll try and get some good ones Steven
says says John I'm friends with Rhonda
Drake step daughter of Sonny Curtis she
has a venue in Franklin North Carolina
named after Sunny if show up some Friday
night
if show up some I'm not sure what he was
trying to say maybe if you want to show
up oh if you want to show up some Friday
night typo very cool Legend all right
uh-oh looks like we got some uh a lot a
lot a lot of drama comments what start
reading Jimbo says so many came here to
spread hate not realizing their views
and commentary help boost the algorithm
for Old Timmy boy you don't like it
watch something else otherwise you're
clowning yourselves well I appreciate
the Super Chat and uh appreciate it and
then I also I put up a poll and I said
smash the like button if you don't trust
Eliza blue and 89 said I will like
because I don't trust her that means
everybody who smashed the thumbs down
trusts Eliza blue all right well that
was an interesting uh it's thirteen
thousand votes it's interesting to see
that so many people came here to uh
support her by giving us a thumbs down
well I can't say I'm surprised a lot of
people do support
Scouts mcgoat says last night as a
member if Tim doesn't disavow Eliza
tonight get the outskirts mcgoat you can
cancel right now and see you later you
will never wave money in my face and
make me disavow anybody especially
someone I care so little about Eliza
blue she's been in the show two times if
you're gonna cancel because I won't do
what you say you shouldn't have been
here in the first place bye-bye don't
let the door hit your ass on the way out
all right what else do we got uh DJ Zeno
says unsubbed on members only after over
a year here's five Fu dollars for you
know I'm pretty bummed thought you stood
against censorship hope you change see
you later buddy look sad to see you go
but uh I will never cater to a mob and
uh that's it end of story uh Eliza blue
is not important she's not important to
me she's not a member of Congress she
doesn't enact policy she is a a low-tier
internet personality that for some
reason people are desperately obsessed
with and I literally don't care so uh
have a nice day I I gotta say this if if
if someone got banned off Twitter or any
platform for a reason other than
violating the terms of service that's a
big deal it should be taken up and and
will be if it happened with the Twitter
Administration or the administration of
social network but the personal stuff is
it it's it's innate it's like no offense
TMZ TMZ garbage it's like National
Enquirer I mean if you like it oh God
questioning you I don't care if people
care about this stuff they're allowed to
but like the idea that people are going
to come here and threaten like I I will
cancel my membership because you're not
talking about someone no one ever heard
of it's like dude I get that you know
who she is but you know what's funny
about Jack Murphy and Eliza blue is that
here's what here's what happens people
ask questions about these personalities
and I know most people listening are
like I have no idea who these people are
and that's exactly it with we had about
40 000 Peak concurrent viewers we get
you know 300 to 500 000 uh video viewers
plus a hundred thousand on the podcast
and then about a million across the
clips and the people who watch have no
idea what the people in the chat are
talking about when it comes to Eliza
blue or Jack Murphy in fact John do you
know who Eliza blue is the only reason I
knew is because I saw you guys talking
about it one time one time I've never
learned about her organically no so what
I think is going on to be completely
honest is that the people who are
claiming they hate her are actually
probably a paid reputational term to
promote her so that's why I brought this
up last week there there are companies
you can hire that will spam the internet
to generate buzz and attention for you
either there's such thing as bad press
so when I see people like flooding our
comments and saying things that aren't
true like I'm canceling my membership yo
I can see who's canceling the
memberships like I can literally I own
the website and this past this past uh
week we have gained slightly more
members than we normally gain and it's
probably because the guests we had on
last week or whatever and uh whatever
jackposovic maybe he's he's a great
personality and so we we gained several
hundred per week and we gained a little
bit more than that on average with
people coming in claiming that they're
they're canceling their memberships
maybe they are but we're gaining more
than they're being canceled I think that
many of these people I think two things
are happening one a lot of it's
inorganic promotion of Eliza blue
a ton of content flooding the internet
bringing up a personality no one's ever
heard of makes her instantly famous to
even the likes of you know nine-time
Grammy nominee John Rich who's not heard
of her that's the point they want us to
talk about her because they're being
paid to generate controversy they either
wanna that's why it doesn't matter if we
say anything good or bad yeah if we say
look we're doing the story Shane
cashman's nope nope it's bad we say okay
we're not going to talk oh nope now it's
bad I think it's a it's a it's a PR
campaign
in order I think people are being paid
to promote to promoter yeah it keeps you
in the cycle basically that's right
everyone she's never been more famous
because of this exactly and so I'll be
completely honest with the Shane Cashman
story I told Shane Cashman I didn't want
him to do the story because he went from
profiling yay to Carrie Lake and now to
a low mid-tier internet personality over
over you know that I just think the next
he like he was supposed to be
interviewing Andrew Tate we we reached
out to Tate I you know I as Shane
mentioned this may kill the story and uh
Tate said yes and so we were like this
is this is great Shane writes tremendous
work I said I don't think he should do
it because clearly they're trying to
promote Eliza blue that's what this
whole thing is about she's never been
more famous and I just I think it's
beneath him but he said look man I
really really want to want to dig in and
and do the story it's 80 000 words it's
massive and I'm like look man you do
your thing I'm not gonna tell you what
you can or can't write I I trust you at
timcast we don't tell people they have
to say something they can't say things
someone wants to post offensive
offensive memes on social media I'm not
going to fire him over it Shane comes to
me and says it's a story I got to tell I
say you tell you you do your thing but
I'm telling everybody who's uh uh you
know who's listening and doesn't know
who this is I'll just explain right now
there's a massive campaign from high
profile personalities to promote and
make Eliza blue famous she has stated
she wants to be famous even to Shane
Cashman and so they're coming and
spamming us with comments to force us to
talk about her like we are right now to
make her more famous it's working and
I'm Des I was like let's let's not let's
not go anywhere near this because
someone's getting paid it's a PR stunt
and it's working yeah there you go guys
I've addressed it have a nice day and
then all of these other people who I
know like who have been members of this
channel are saying like why won't you
get on board bro you are walking right
into a PR game I talked about how they
do this they're called reputation
management firms you go to them and you
say how much money to make me a star and
they'll say we're gonna do a two-front
thing we're gonna say you're fighting a
good fight but you got controversy that
way we get you on both fronts people
will defend you people will oppose you
and this will result in high profile
Outlets The Daily Beast will write about
you you're gonna get a bunch of you know
grifter channels are going to start
talking about you drama channels big
YouTubers we will make you famous and
it'll cost you 100 Grand and there you
go congratulations everybody you did
exactly what the money paid for and here
we are addressing it just for you hope
the money was worth it all right let's
uh let's read more
all right Thomas pant says think about
why Dave Mustaine no longer has a
satanic imagery or plays certain songs
you can't be ironic about that for long
before it becomes sincere and has a
spiritual cost
um
all right grafty says UFOs spin buck
buck I don't believe you buck buck I'm
gonna spin that UFO just gotta spin by
the way I know Dave Mustang pretty well
it was the satanic thing an act
I don't know if it was an act back in
the day but I know that's not what he is
now
so that that comment actually makes a
lot of sense Marilyn Manson I wonder if
he was satanic too do you know Marilyn I
don't know don't know him but I do know
Dave and I I you yeah you're right you
don't see that stuff in Dave's show
anymore interesting
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim my guy the
same folks I love them my guy by the way
it's a funny thing there's two things
that I think are really funny right now
it's my guy and the boys saying the boys
the boys Chicago Yeah Tim my guy the
same folks who cry and spam non-stop
over Twitter will never get off their
butts to knock doors or harvest ballots
a real-life mission for the betterment
of all of us cry more Jeremy Raymond the
reason why they don't is because it's
inorganic it's a PR stunt where you hire
a firm to generate controversy some
people are either paid I don't know or
join in because it looks like it's
generating traffic but the goal is
people who want to be famous and we know
there are people who have admitted that
they're trying to be famous we'll go to
a reputation management firm and say
here's 50 Grand make me famous and they
will then spam YouTube spam comments and
their goal is to get YouTubers to see a
wave of comments saying please talk
about this then they go okay I will they
will then do this as a very clever thing
Ryan holiday did this he bought a
billboard for Tucker Max
and then vandalized it himself
then he called a radio station and said
what's this billboard that just got
vandalized
so then it became a controversy
manufactured so you want to know why I
think these people got censored on uh on
on Twitter I think it's possible and I
won't I'll just keep it vague it is a PR
stunt
targeting people who talk about free
speech with censorship to trick them
into promoting an individual trying to
be famous and they all walked right into
it it is it is PR stunt 101. it also
makes me think there are situations
where a Creator would pay a firm to do
it 50 Grand or whatever but then there's
also the impact investment that there
could be companies that try and find
people on the internet like content
creators that are like we're gonna make
this one famous because they are talking
about a thing we need to be talked about
right now dude it's literally
astroturfing it's like the definition
what's happening it's clever yeah you
you spam someone's comments saying talk
about this person once they do you then
use your multiple accounts to to flag
them triggering triggering an
algorithmic censorship campaign you then
use the Bots to spam a conspiracy theory
you then start I mean look I I think
somebody paid to make Eliza blue famous
and the people who are commenting are
trying to make her famous yeah like one
of the first things John said to me was
like you know what's you asked me about
Eliza blue and then I was like oh you
you know her you're like oh no I just
heard from this right and yeah I've
never heard of her and I went I don't
know who that is but I saw it I saw you
were talking about her and I went and I
saw there there was some
debate going on I thought well I should
probably know what's going on with this
I'm getting ready to see Tim and
everybody so I dug in on it a little bit
and it was back and forth and back and
forth like a ping pong match I went
that's exactly it right there so then I
went and bought her t-shirt ball cap
I will be at the Eliza blue concert
whenever that happens the idea the idea
is I want to open for you but this is a
Horse Ride a Cowboy but this this is a
good one yeah this is a a good point you
made is that you couldn't make heads or
tails of it no because it's confusing
that's the point of the PR stunt they
don't want to create a negative
perception they want to create
name recognition so for a lot of people
it's a negative name recognition for
Eliza blue now it's a negative response
for you who is trying to like what is
this you're I don't know but you heard
of her and that's all that matters it's
like that line from Pirates of the
Caribbean when the guy says you are the
worst pirate I've ever heard of and he
goes but you have heard of me all right
yeah yep and so people are like why
won't Tim talk about it because you know
what man I caved the pr firm guys are
sitting in there a room in West
Hollywood laughing their asses off
saying we got it it normally cost you
know how many tens of thousands of
dollars or how many thousands of dollars
to get a promotional push on timcast he
just came out and talked about it for 10
minutes for us congratulations guys you
work for a PR firm you've made her more
famous than she's ever been more famous
than she's ever been there you go
but the reality is most of the people
spamming us they're not real people like
a lot of people are a lot of people are
not so uh you you may you one guy makes
ten accounts one guy makes it you get
Five Guys you get 50 accounts they post
comments they accuse you they create a
perception then they start sending those
comments to journalists saying please
write about this yeah I think a lot of
people maybe got kind of drawn up in the
drama and the Motions of it but really
like if Britney venti got banned for
violating the not violating terms of
service that's the story if she violated
terms of service then it was a righteous
ban I think the real story is that she
likely got banned as part of a campaign
where someone trying to become famous
hires a company who then spams someone's
comments with fake accounts to get them
to talk about it then immediately use
those accounts to do Mass flagging which
results in an algorithmic censorship
meaning no one at Twitter actually
looked and saw it when Twitter receives
a certain amount of flags in a certain
amount of time so does YouTube and
Facebook they instantly take it down
because of things like Gore live stream
to murder and things like that then the
streamer then comes out and screams oh
I've been censored because they have
been and that generates the story which
makes the person famous so it's just
it's just too obvious I'm not going to
be involved in that stuff that's the
extent that I'm willing to be involved
in it and to anybody who has no idea who
these people are I thought it was worth
talking about so you can understand how
these these PR reputation management
firms work how they generate images of
individuals
for the sake of making them famous and
it's funny because everyone's like Eliza
blue just wants to be famous
congratulations you just made her family
if you made her real famous than anyone
ever if that is true Eliza you gotta
remember why are you why do you want to
be famous do what you want the fame is a
byproduct she literally says it to Shane
Cashman that's what she I've been there
I know what it's like to want it but why
do you want it because the people that
follow you will follow you because of
the why and if you have grifters
following you it's not going to be a
good life let's uh let's read this one
from Quan Shin Singaporean here stop
saying the police will come after you
for not flushing like you did in your
member section that's not even remotely
a real thing ask Serge love your shows
even though there are some things that
disagree with appreciate it what do you
say I've never heard that before but the
flushing and toilet saying no but it is
yeah he's right it's meant to be there
to stop you from doing things but if you
go and walk around MRT you'll see
there's no gum on the side on the bottom
of the ground if you go in like child's
bike yeah it's just not a thing because
people realize I was told by local
singaporeans
that yeah that may be part of it they
may be saying like hey what they're
trying to say to you is don't play games
don't push your luck because they'll
come down on you they said if you finish
eating like a restaurant and leave your
tray people will get really mad they'll
shame you they'll post pictures yeah or
you can get a ticket if there's like a
cop and they see you doing it because
littering or whatever and they said
literally like if you don't flush the
toilet you leave it a mess the same
thing could happen and they're like
there's stories of like cops being in a
bathroom and then someone walking out
and I'm noticing and I'm giving you a
ticket or something like that keep
Singapore clean I'm not saying it's you
know I don't know I was that's all I was
talking my kids get in trouble if they
don't flush the toilet and my kids get
in trouble if they leave all their all
their their plates on the counter I like
the way you run the house yeah well yeah
man I mean what hope does the world have
if you don't raise kids that have some
kind of sense dude the contract with
your son is epic that contract on the
iPhone anybody out there that's a parent
you got a kid want an iPhone make them
sign a contract because if he ever
breaks the contract you just go I think
you just lost your phone but let's check
the contract then you go back and see
what the word's saying subsection four
this is a burger four we got to go in
here from Owen Vier Sema Mr John Rich by
the bank in Jamestown Michigan there's a
bank for sale
hmm well we bought one in Oklahoma
we call it Old Glory Bank
um old glorybank.com so the point of
this bank it's Ben Carson Larry Elder
myself a bunch of big institutional Bank
guys that are patriots that stepped away
from the woke Banks out there across
this country and the whole premise of
the bank is you will never be canceled
for exercising your constitutional
rights we saw it happen in Canada what
you know we're seeing it happen in
Brazil it's going to happen in this
country it's already starting to happen
with various companies and people and so
we thought you know what unless you
unless you want to be completely uh
pigeonholed and stuck you better come up
with something else and so this is a
this is a bank for Patriots run by
Patriots where you'll never have your
bank weaponized against you can I open
an account if I'm not living in that
state yeah you can open account anywhere
in the U.S so the physical bank is in
Oklahoma there will be more online Oh
Glory Bank you can reserve an account
we're up we got tens of thousands of
accounts already reserved let's do it
yeah we got a coffee shop that's open
well well Tim here's the thing everybody
wants to run for the hills but what hill
are you going to run because the enemy
owns all the hills so you got to go
build new Hills for people to run to
that that that's in entertainment it's
in banking if they if you don't have a
secure bank account if somebody can just
turn it off because you went on you went
on temcast John rich and we don't like
Tim cast so we're gonna freeze your bank
account you went to the wrong protest
you made the wrong social media post
whatever you own the wrong rifle
we're gonna shut you off well there's
people in this country that really
fantasize about being able to do that
and and they probably will pull it off
at some point this bank had to happen I
hope other platforms show up like that
too run by real Freedom free-thinking
people that would never punish you for
exercising your constitutional right
what a concept that freedom is now a
marketing angle
what a concept what a comment that is on
our country that saying you won't be
punished for exercising your
constitutional rights is a marketing
angle but that's where we're at all
right let's read we got this one from
part axolis he says I live I live close
to Kamloops John rich is a legend in
Canada my buddy Tai has an epic story
about meeting him in Prince George
okay all right probably does was
camroops cam loops that's way up North
that's north of like north of Fort
McMurray yeah I think so yeah I'm from
my family's from Newfoundland so oh okay
yeah I've been up there too is it Saint
t St John
uh that's the cat I mean that's the
capital yeah it was a small town yeah
yeah
no candidate listen in the dead of
winter you go play Canada because
there's nothing going on and every
hockey rink is packed with 10 000 people
that that's that's how we do it yeah we
go tour the coldest I've ever been Fort
McMurray Alberta in January of 2006
where your nose sticks together because
the inside of your nose freezes yeah
yeah that's cool you learn to live with
the cold voice the Elder Millennial says
Tim you just re-earned my subscription
for this and next month you address it
perfectly keep growing Rich you're great
spin the UFO meditate often hey
appreciate it I'll spin it again all
right Bliss girl says big shout out to
Ian your sacrifice kindness and care for
Mr bocus I added the mister is a
testament to the goodness of humanity no
matter what happens you've enhanced the
quality of his life for an extended time
many blessings and you have rolled a 20
in perpetuity thank you yes he's doing
well I reintroduced toys we've been
playing a lot the wild animal
um I have some update on Buck go now
that you brought him up I mentioned last
week that he had a reaction to the
preservative that the stem cells were
kept in when he had the injection that
he went into some heavy breathing it was
expected uh it's not considered a
preservative technically I called vet
stem which is the company that spun the
the stem cells down and they let me know
it's what happens is the stem cells are
cultured in a Cell media product that's
proprietary mix that stem nose I don't
know what it is but vetston's got it
it's proteins electrolytes in a serum
albumin and then it's washed his stem
cells are washed in Saline and then put
back into his own serum and then that's
how it's reintroduced to the cat a lot
of times animals will just have a
reaction from that if you do anything to
manage it no no it's just a short burst
of like heavy breathing and a little bit
of exhaustion while the body's working
it and then he's back to normal he's
back to normal by the time he got back
but he was tired yeah and I think he's
going in for another round on Thursday
it sounded good yeah is he gaining
weight yeah man I mean he looks great
you should come see him yeah what's that
Mr Brokers Academy yeah oh no I've seen
it yeah he was he was staying with me
and Allison with with uh Allison and me
what is it
and me if it's after the verb
you say Allison and I were watching him
after the verb it's watching him with
Allison and me are you sure you know
what you're talking about I'm a grammar
I feel strongly about this stuff the one
Nazi I am is a grammar Nazi and then uh
so anyway when uh Ian came to pick him
up
and bring him in for his stems
harvesting all that afterwards we were
like you know he should stay with Ian
because you know you brought him took
him back and gonna take care of him we
thought it was a good idea for uh for
you know and plus managing the stem
cells and stuff it's working out but uh
you know but you know Allison's saying
she's like we got to get Focus back he's
got yeah he'll be back no but I I think
it's good that you guys are um getting
the treatment and staying up on that
because if we switched like we don't
know what you know and if you started it
we want you to see it through it even
gets a little just Kara and I working
together to feed him there's two of us
that can get a little confusing it's
really good to have like you know one
person one person in church plus it's
good for him the chaos I think yeah
having he knows who he's going home to
staying in one stable place must be
comforting animals are some of my
favorite people they're amazing right
all right truly the personalities
absolutely let's uh we'll we'll read two
more here
uh well a couple more Dylan sulking says
Tim will never read my super chats
Miss Mary says I'm not a paid botan been
a supporter for years I hope you realize
what an insane take this is this is an
insult to your viewers and supporters
well I got nothing else to say I mean
look uh Eliza can't make anyone happy
are you joking right no I just that's
why it's like I don't care dude look man
I've been I've been around this this for
so long I've said it before I'll say it
again it Ebbs and flows there are people
who will like you then they'll hate you
a year later they demand that you talk
about things they will support you for
standing up for what you believe and
then get mad when you don't believe what
they want you to believe literally don't
care Miss Mary like by all means if you
don't like the content and uh you're not
a supporter anymore that's just the way
things are going there's nothing there's
nothing I'm not gonna lie to you I'm not
gonna sit here and be like oh gee well
let me say what I have to say so I can
earn your five dollars like dude if you
don't want to give me five dollars don't
give me five dollars that's all I can
say all right
all right what else do we got
um I think there was one more
Jared V says Jeremy is live and trying
to break down what you're saying what do
you have to say about that you literally
said you don't care about Eliza so what
else is there to say yeah it's a really
really good point Eliza is an irrelevant
figure who's trying to be famous and
y'all are making her famous she's not in
Congress she doesn't know anybody she's
not she's I guess she's talked with like
Jack Dorsey in the past but she is just
like it's remarkable to me when uh
Jeremy Hambly goes on his show and says
something like Tim won't address the
Jack Murphy stuff and it's like
interesting
I wonder if anybody who is paying
attention to a Chinese balloon carrying
potential explosives of the United
States is concerned about what some some
video some guy produced so if like
you're interested in interpersonal drama
and e-girl celebrity stuff Tim cast is
not the channel for you and if that's
the case and then I don't want your
money like dude it's it's remarkable
that people are like Tim if you don't
address Eagle drama I'm Gonna Cancel I'm
like okay all right we'll cancel against
I don't know you know we're gonna do
this week we are going to be uh
potentially talking with some members of
Congress and um because I what I'm
concerned about is will people have
enough money to pay their bills will
fuel prices be too high is China
preparing for an attack on Taiwan what I
don't care about is did e-girl lie to
get famous there's Abraham Lincoln oh
quote I was going to introduce I was
gonna say like you're allowed to care
about that that's fine but don't be
surprised that I don't and don't care
about it and don't want to talk about it
and that's just it the Abe Lincoln quote
that I imagine everyone knows so I
didn't bring it up but I guess they
don't is that you can please some of the
people all of the time and all of the
people some of the time but you can't
please all of the people all the time
that's right and then he freed the
slaves
he said he wouldn't know well that's
mine all right everybody a story if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it become a member at timcast.com
because apparently there's a whole bunch
of people who would prefer that we
talked about e-drama instead of
everything we talked about if uh you're
sad that those people no longer support
us then you can support us directly if
you think we're better off talking about
ideas political issues cultural Concepts
and and big cultural forces and you
think that is something that is worth
supporting then go to timcast.com and
support our work there we're gonna have
a members only show coming up talking
about some of these cultural issues
it'll be up in about an hour you can all
you can follow the show at timcastirl
basically everywhere I got some some
news to apparently we're starting to
kill it on Facebook I never cared for
Facebook get Zuckerberg in but now uh
Thursday yeah Mark we've been posting
everything to Facebook we just basically
ignored it and actually it's like really
big now we're getting a ton of traffic
and I'm really surprised to see like
millions and millions and so I'm kind of
like okay maybe we should have used
Facebook from the get-go so thank you
everybody watching on Facebook bring
back Myspace now yeah
let me personally at timcast John do you
want to shout anything out
um redneck Riviera baby my Whiskey's
doing great 10 000 Plus stores
redneckriviera.com we've now given over
a million bucks back to the folds of
Honor anybody out there that's active
duty or a veteran thank you for your
service without you guys and gals we
don't get to have shows like this we
don't get to have anything matter of
fact so God bless each and every one of
you and thanks for having me back on
your show brother I appreciate it right
on uh I'm Hannah Claire rimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should follow
at timcastnews on Twitter and you should
all follow at timcast news on Instagram
you can follow me personally at
Instagram I can't remember anything
right now uh at my I'm so sorry Hannah B
okay you can follow me I'm gonna just
talk to you
you can follow me on Instagram at
hannahclear.b you can also follow me on
Twitter at hcbromo I was thinking about
what I was gonna say maybe that's why
you got distracted looking at you but
not thinking about it I've heard my
intros are not long enough and I I'm not
prepared to make my outros longer yeah
that one was great John always a
pleasure awesome to see you man yes sir
good seeing you as well I want to give a
special shout out to Jeremy Hambly if
you're listening buddy I love you man
um you got a great brain and I like it
when you talk about the real stuff dude
you really have a good great perception
like you're able to see
when it hits the fan before it's
hitting the fan and I need you just to
stay focused in the the greater culture
scheme of like software and and
development and administration of social
networking and things like that because
you're really brilliant uh and I hope to
see you again soon man I love you
goodbye everyone see you later yeah we
don't kowtow uh Tim cast that's all I
gotta say at surge.com see you guys
later we'll see you all over at
timcast.com or not maybe maybe not or
maybe goodbye forever yeah maybe goodbye
or maybe you'll sign up to see what it's
all about because you're like man
everybody's commenting something about
these this Tim cast membership you
definitely gotta check it out now
because wait till you see what's
happening behind the scenes we'll see
you all over there thanks for hanging
out later